70
billion dollars a bubba billion with a
b wall street firms 5 000
set to lose a combined 70
billion dollars off of their failing
short
positions you see these companies
thought that they could bet against a
lot of these companies
these other companies these retail shops
and then
a bunch of bored people on the internet
said
i don't know i got nothing else to do
let's blow up some hedge funds now of
course they're trying everything in
their power to cheat the system to rig
the system
robinhood and a bunch of other apps have
suspended the trades
trading of certain stocks not just
gamestop
not just amc and they made it personal i
bought some nokia
full disclosure because i like the brand
i think it's a funny meme
about you know them being indestructible
and i thought it was
it was it was a cheap stock and i'm like
yeah sure i'll buy some of this i'm not
going to buy the big you know the rally
whatever
and then they froze it robin hood did
and i could only sit there and watch as
the value just crumbled and tanked they
stole from me
personally that's dirty well now we got
word
that there's going to be some
congressional hearings i mean this is
this is getting really really big
we've got this there's a viral post
right now where someone claiming to be
an
insider may not be real at all but we
will talk about it
there's a lot more stories but a lot of
it really has to do with what's going on
with uh with this with this gamestop
stuff because there's some physical
protests happening
protests happening in the real world and
so we'll talk about this we'll go
through uh
you know just what's happening with this
this the great gamestop rebellion
and i think the 70 billion numbers is a
huge victory for them
but uh joining us today is survivor
advocate
you want to introduce yourself yeah hi
everybody my name is eliza
i go by lizable on twitter so it's
e-l-i-z-a-b-l-e-u
and i'm a survivor advocate for those
affected by human trafficking
right on i'm also a survivor of human
trafficking is there anything else you
wanted to add i don't know if you want
to
we're going to go we're going to tread
really lightly okay yeah yeah right on
and uh of course luke caskey is hanging
out well they're going after free speech
they're going after the free market both
are illusions because we're not in the
big
club just like george carlin said howdy
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings this is ogdowski of we are
change.org
if you want to find out more information
about me check out my youtube channel we
are changed thanks for having me
we also got hey ian crossland what's up
everybody at ian crossland all over the
internet and i want to know
personally what you guys think is
dogecoin itself
a protest hmm good question dogecoin
skyrocketing to the moon 500 that's not
a protest
i don't know what they're doing with
dogecoin it's like they're moving all
that all that
robinhood money into doge well there's a
lot of talk about moving away from the
stock market going to alternatives
especially with the dollar with silver
with gold with cryptocurrency so there's
a lot of wild talk happening right now
all over the internet i think we're in
very exciting times
but also in a time where we're seeing
that
you know the markets are being just
absolutely manipulated for the benefit
of the special interests for the special
class that live under a different set of
rules than everyone else the stock
market is
now officially a socialist organization
meanwhile
you know things like the blockchain are
the actual capitalistic
institutions that are actually somewhat
freer and a lot
more decentralized than of course the
centralized big brother
big oligarch controlled interests that
of course we have
we're going to talk about dogecoin yeah
i guess
i guess we have to elon musk yeah i love
that i love that elon musk tweeted about
it i
honestly i love anytime elon does that i
feel like it's like a little like
a little pump up for the plebs i feel
like he's trying to give it to like the
little guy
you know i'm a pleb by the way and i
always keep it real with people like i'm
a pleb but
i just love that elon's always trying to
help out the plays by like boosting
stuff but
i believe lex freeman tweeted out today
the internet always wins yep
it's so correct ladies and gentlemen
this is a hornet's nest
i think it's amazing and wall street
and then they kicked it again and they
kicked it again and then big tech
stepped up
and kicked the hornets and they're
getting stung like crazy and they just
keep kicking it what's wrong with these
people
i released a meme with that uh or with
that with that pink
guy looking at uh with one of the batman
characters and it says uh redditer with
weaponized autism versus of course wall
street and wall street's this little guy
and you got the little weirdo coming in
there we're living in extremely
special times that are absolutely
exciting and
it's crazy listen listen listen i was
gonna wear that outfit tonight by the
way
that was my other look it's not that
complicated when you have
one person whose total risk is three
hundred dollars
but you have five million of them and
then you have a hedge fund
one fund whose total risk is in the
infinite because they're
shorting and it's gonna direct i mean 70
billion dollars between 5000 firms
a lot of money i think uh one of these
firms is looking at losing a billion
dollars
their risk is massive so these
individuals are like i'm not going to
lose that much i don't care
it's almost like if a million people all
took one dollar
and gave that one dollar to you you'd be
a millionaire and they'd have only lost
a dollar
right it's that simple so this is the
future this is decentralization this is
the internet
it's going to get fun well we'll get
into all this and we'll definitely talk
about that before we do we got a good
sponsor today my favorite sponsor
virtual shield everybody make sure you
check out surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get access to a virtual
private network a secure
it is a security system for you as you
browse the internet
it allows you to browse safely and
securely and they've got fifty percent
off for life it's only two dollars and
fifty cents
per month virtual shield is my first
sponsor they've always been there for us
they're really great
and i'll tell you a few things about
them first and foremost virtual shield
is compatible with all devices it allows
you to browse the web safely securely
and
anonymously using their global network
of servers and private ips
it lets you browse the web completely
anonymously so the big name
internet service providers and other
third parties will not be able to
monitor and sell your internet activity
and browsing history when using their
vpn service your traffic is routed
through secure and encrypted servers
it means that any restrictions
censorship blocks on your internet
are bypassed you can enjoy browsing a
fast reliable secure and always
available network and it is free for the
first 30 days
it works on mac windows iphone ipad
android and chrome and it does all the
work for you
your entire connection becomes secure
private and encrypted and i'll put it
this way make it very simple for people
i always put it like
you've got locks on your windows you got
locks on your doors it is that simple
layer of security now if somebody really
wanted to they'll break your window in
but it's it deters
that initial attempt right makes sense i
think most people agree
most people however don't don't use any
security at all so
when if you're concerned about big tech
companies governments or whoever trying
to spy on you
this is your basic level of defense so
check out surfing internetsafe.com
you will find uh virtual shields vpn
service free for the first 30 days 50
off seriously thank you so much to
virtual shield for sponsoring this
podcast
and uh before we jump into the news
don't forget to go to timcast.com
sign up to become a member for exclusive
members only posts and we're going to
get
really really serious in the members
only post and i'll tell you why
it has a lot to do with the news of
right now youtube
makes it very very difficult to tell you
what's really going on
with things like human trafficking
that's why eliza is here
and so we'll we'll try and talk about as
much as we can but i'm not trying to be
you know i don't a lot of people say oh
tim you're a coward and you just gotta
say it listen
i've thought along a lot about what we
can and can't talk about and how we talk
about it but
should i sacrifice talking about 99
of things for one percent of things and
it makes it very difficult that's why we
set up timcast.com
so we can tell you we are going to go
we're going to go hard on the subject of
human trafficking
and a lot of what's going on in a way
that youtube won't allow and we'll do it
on the website
so that's timcast.com it also helps to
make sure that the event we eventually
do get
banned or suspended or whatever happens
because the purge is here
your membership helps us keep working
and making sure that that you know that
flow of information remains
that being said thank you all so much to
smash the like button hit the subscribe
button the notification bell
and uh we'll jump into that first story
let me let me give a shout out to sour
patch liz real quick because i don't
think we gave her a proper intro too
yeah shout out to her
she's been an amazing host she's been
amazing to me
i'm happy to help and i wanted to add to
the metaphor about the vpn
um ben's ben mentioned that it's
actually also like tinting your windows
because you may lock your door and your
windows like having a firewall
but people can still see inside if
you're not using
the vpn there you go
do you have a car i do have a car yet
what i would do i don't have tinder
windows on my car though
okay i used to have 10 windows that's
what i bought the car in miami
it's like everybody's got tinted windows
because that is just brutally hot yeah
yeah do you expect windows i don't know
the most important news only the best
let's jump into the first story
so i covered this on my main channel but
this is huge i i think we're gonna have
a really fun conversation
from reuters losses on short positions
in u.s firms top
70 billion dollars so i'll just
that's the news there it is boom they
say what is it 5 000
firms uh the loss chasing shorted
companies became a trend among retail
traders rippling across the u.s markets
and
europe or texas data showed as of
wednesday there were loss making short
positions on more than 5
000 u.s firms to put it simply
what you are seeing in the great
gamestop rebellion
it's uh some people are calling it
occupy wall street 2.0
the new slogan being power to the
players of course that's that was the
chant of occupy as most of you know it
is now i suppose
but you know what's really crazy they
destroyed our businesses they shut
everything down they locked everyone up
everyone got really really angry and did
a bunch of different things with that
with that anger
and then when the riots stopped over
black lives matter and then we saw the
storm at the capitol there's still that
anger it's not going anywhere
and then all of a sudden these uh
redditors
were like yo we're gonna short squeeze
these hedge funds out of billions of
dollars
and here's what i don't think i think
people don't realize and often when it
comes to online activism
the initial activists are probably just
doing it for the lulz it's
funny so wall street bets are like we
make money we tell people hey we're
gonna buy this the price goes up and
then they gamble right
but then some real angry people saw it
populists on the left and the right
saw what was happening and thought i
like i like the results of this
and now before it was just these wall
street bets
bored young people with stimulus checks
now you've got a bunch of
righteous indignation i suppose people
who aren't don't know what stocks are
don't know how trading works aren't on
robin hood
aren't on any of these apps and they're
like i'm in and they throw their money
at it
so what's happening now is i mentioned
this in the in the intro
these wall street firms their exposure
is nearly infinite
the shorts can keep climbing as the
value keeps growing
but for most of these people that are
thrown in a couple bucks or throwing a
couple hundred bucks
their risk is literally just that money
if i buy a stock for 10 bucks and the
stock hits zero i lost 10 bucks i don't
care
but if you have five million people
doing that all putting in that money now
you've got 50 million
dollars invested in these companies sure
50 million dollars could be lost but for
an individual it's not that much
so this is what's happening now the
power of the people in play
a concerted effort it's almost like
everybody's shining a flash at the same
time creating this
massive blinding light essentially what
happened here is a bunch of people got
together on the internet and
outsmarted the hedge funds the hedge
funds aren't that smart to begin with
right
and they literally they literally
outplayed them in their own
game and what did the the the
controllers of this game do what did the
billionaires do
well they flipped the table over and
made it illegal for people to even
win on main street unless you're a part
of the secret group on wall street they
colluded together they delisted a whole
bunch of stocks to of course make them
go broke and this is the insanity of it
they're conspiring colluding together to
make sure
businesses go out of business for the
benefit
of vultures that are going to be making
money off of that stock going down
they're making sure companies no longer
have money to function with this is
absolutely insane
you know you know what i was thinking
when donald trump got elected i was like
wow the elites sure screwed this one up
the establishment really messed this up
donald trump wasn't supposed to get like
they're supposed to be hillary right
something went wrong and i thought to
myself it's interesting because a lot of
people think the elections have always
been rigged
at least for a long time and then when
they discovered that trump won
they weren't or maybe whatever but the
idea was like wow you could actually
vote and it works right
i thought to myself if that conspiracy
is true
that the elections have always been
rigged and there's a unit party that
controls everything
this current generation of establishment
political elites are the worst
it's almost like you know like you have
a kid and the kid's just really bad at
everything like
you know you're the best skateboard in
the world you have a kid and your kid
just sucks at it
that's it this new generation of
establishment elites are just too dumb
to maintain the stranglehold over the
people that's been enjoyed for some time
i'm saying assuming that conspiracy
would be true i'm not saying it is
but more importantly just look because
that's what people were saying like how
did this happen how did trump well trump
won it shows you that you can
but looking at the hedge fund screwing
all this up
colluding with big tech they're doing it
right in front of us
when they're i woke up this morning it's
like i was looking at my nokia stock and
the price is going down
and i'm like i can't buy any i want to
buy the dip it won't let me
they're forcing the market to crash it
is so
obvious what they've what they're doing
to rig the game now and everyone's just
watching them do it you're referencing
like apps like robin hood which is just
cut off trading
to people no no only buying only buying
which means you can sell it to the fat
cats
so the price can go down but you can't
buy it back yeah for full disclosure
just for the lows i bought amc i bought
bed bath and beyond and nokia
all of them going down and and you you
can't buy more
you can only sell it which means the
price can only go down at least on these
apps
you've got to go to other platforms if
you want to try and buy it so this is
like the establishment bankrupting
these companies you know these companies
are losing
people investing into them because again
a
special billionaire circle of
individuals that are connected to
citadel that are connected to all these
larger companies again also full
transparency of what i just invested in
not a financial advisor you got to say
these things just to make sure you got
your
your your eyes dotted and t's crossed
here but but
they're i mean dave portnoy really
really said
something that that really makes sense
to a lot of people and a lot of people
are
repeating this what lock them up and he
just said jail
jail jail for all of them and i agree
put him in jail venezuela i know it's
not going to happen because we have
individuals like janet yellen at the
helm
sorry you had something to say but i
think that one thing that's amazing
about it
is that folks are probably understanding
that they can
even if you don't have much you could
still do something amazing and great
and start to take back some of the power
i don't think people really realize
if they harness that energy what they
could really do with it and so i think
that this is just a slight taste
of what like the players see this is
like return to the plans this is revenge
of the plebs like
you'll see like i think that that's
really amazing when people start to
realize that power
yeah you know well not just that but but
realizing that the markets are being
manipulated yeah they're bogus
they're protecting the wealthiest and
most powerful people in the
establishment
in exchange for screwing over let's get
real after
the hard time we've all have just been
going through
that's a triple slide in the stock
market benefiting from it
it's pretty mean yeah so let them show
you let them show their true colors
and let everybody see it for what it is
so robin hood emailed me
i got this email a lot of people have
already gotten it i guess it's coming
out in
it's staggered or whatever and they say
an update on market conditions hi
timothy
it's been a tough day and we're grateful
should i should i do it more like a
snooty north like
yeah give us more we're grateful for you
being a robin hood customer
in light of the extraordinary market
conditions this week
we temporarily limited buying for
certain securities this morning
starting tomorrow we plan to allow
limited buys of these securities
we'll continue to monitor the situation
and may make adjustments as needed
uh i just want to say i'm not a
financial advisor and you know i'm just
giving my personal opinion
and i'll tell you what i want to do you
know what i want to do tomorrow what
limited buys what's limited mean because
i'm going to hit the max
i'm going to hit that limit right away
boom first thing that's to be determined
yeah i'm offended by what they did i am
too yeah they say this was a temporary
decision made to
made to best continue serving you oh
destroying the value of the stock that
i'm holding
served me well thanks
as a brokerage firm we we have many
financial requirements including sec net
capital obligations and clearinghouse
deposits
some of these requirements fluctuate
based on volatility in the markets
and can be substantial in the current
environment these requirements exist
to protect investors and the markets and
and the markets
and we take our responsibilities to
comply with them seriously
including to the measures we have taken
today to be clear
this decision was not made on the
direction of any market maker
we route to other market participants
you know they just admitted to
they said that their requirements the
sec
capital obligations clearinghouse
deposits they had to do it right
they just said an email to me tim
you [ __ ] the game is rigged we're
telling you it's rigged
when the game is set up in such a way
that you benefit the sec requires us
to jam okay i'm not going to get that
offensive it's a family-friendly show
calm down requires us to slap you in the
face
that's right so when the hedge funds
burn the country to the ground
but they're too big to fail we better
give them some money off your back
how many people suffered 12 years ago
how many people's homes were under water
and still are and it's true for a lot of
people and they're telling you right now
but there are certain capital
obligations the sec requires of us
what they just said to me when you get
it right and you guys figure the game
out
the system requires that we smack you in
the face and knock you down
i don't care to read the rest of this
garbage we stand in support of you our
customers oh it's written in bold oh
amazing i'm involved yeah do you believe
it a little more it's like
it's like they're urinating on you and
telling you it's raining yeah
but you guys this is like this is the
tails all this time they've been doing
listen i know this is a tale is all this
time yeah if you're just getting hit to
it this is how it's always been
so we have to be the change but listen
that's it you're right
but we thought the system was was was
weighted
you know what i mean we thought the die
we yeah
we thought the system was weighted most
people i should say folks are coming to
the conclusion
what i'm saying is most people think
that the dye
is loaded it can still land on seven you
can still win it's just really hard yeah
now we're learning they got some kind of
gizmo in it and they flick a button and
it always lands
for them snake eyes no no no no no
matter what you lose they took the dice
and they rammed it up where the sun
doesn't shine
and they're telling you go do a little
happy dance with your little dice inside
of you and good luck getting anything in
there but also
the most other surprising aspect for a
lot of people
it isn't for us because we cover this we
know the game is right for a while and
you bring up some good points here
is the reaction from big tech in the
mainstream media according to reuters
facebook has taken down the popular wall
street discussion group robin hood stock
traders
and and also another group so facebook
is banning it we heard discord's banning
it but
we saw cnn yesterday describe this to
trumpism
yeah npr was talking about here we go
liking this to gamergate
because of harassment of hedge fund
managers there's mainstream media
journalists who are tweeting out annoyed
gifts
who are saying oh this is just like
gamergate are you trying it's not going
to work
yeah but my my point before was just
that
the system before was rigged we all
thought so now we're learning it's not
that it's rigged
because even in a rigged system you
think you can find a way to get through
no no this this system is not just
rigged there's bodyguards blocking you
if you actually make it past a certain
threshold they're like no no
that wasn't supposed to happen get out
there's it's a big club you ain't in it
and there's no open door for anyone i
support the united states constitution
i'm an american
i love our country and our laws and a
lot of them but
i don't support the federal reserve in
the u.s dollar right now i am
totally out and off and have lost total
confidence in that
machination i think it is ridiculous to
trust that system right now
and if that makes me sound un-american
that's a big problem
because the federal reserve is not an
american company well we have to
understand
the previous federal reserve chairman
janet yellen is now
the head of the treasury department and
the biden administration was
literally literally literally asked
today are you guys going to do anything
about this where's the press conference
is there going to be some news about
this
they responded with by saying uh
especially when asked about janet yellen
getting eight hundred and ten
thousand dollars from the citadel group
the citadel group by the way
is the one that invests in melvin
capital it's the one
that also robin hood's uh it's robin
hood's biggest customer
so she got ten thousand dollars for her
speech
and the white house officially responded
with by saying oh she she deserved that
money and she's also a woman
she's a woman yes she's a woman wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold on and she
deserved it
because she's smart wait it's a woman
treasure secretary yes yes
oh well we're good yeah yeah yeah thanks
for hanging out everybody
saved by but but but you brought up a
good point because if you think
someone's giving a 45-minute speech for
810 000
for wisdom you're absolutely idiotic and
stupid when you're paying someone
that large sum of money she got 7.2
million dollars from wall street firms
within two years for
speeches when you're giving her that
much money you're not buying wisdom
you're buying uh influence you're buying
someone that's going to be
that's going to be doing your bidding
and that's exactly what we're seeing
with this larger inaction here why
didn't you just start a non-profit
that they could donate to yeah you know
that's that's the way you get away with
it
they i can't i love it when you know
hillary clinton went around doing
speeches for goldman sachs
just before she announced he was going
to run for president you you had a bunch
of journalists even saying
oh hillary clinton hasn't announced yet
but she just gave a 200
dollar 45 minute speech that's their
donation to her campaign
and she's going to run that's how people
know yeah it's dirty politics it's dirty
it's the dirty markets and i'll tell you
what look at scary because we've talked
about it quite a bit since this uh
gamergate
gamer gamestop rebellion there we go
game stop rebellion there you go
when people try to vote and whether it's
bernie or trump
they end up losing now bernie lost twice
trump got in for four years then he
loses now people are feeling like their
vote's just not going to get them what
they want
i mean people voted for biden because
they hated trump and now they're stuck
with biden
janet yellen they're not happy about
that so what happens when that doesn't
work well now they're going to financial
markets because they're bored and got
nothing to do
and these and and and you're seeing
these super rich people freaking out
getting angry about it
but the people you know idol was saying
idol hands the devil's playground yes
well that's that's something that the
wall street fund should be saying right
now
because you've got a you've got an
economy shuttered
and a bunch of people sitting around
saying what do i do i'm angry
and then some dude goes hey you know
that stimulus check you got they just
put a little bit into this stock they'll
lose billions of dollars
okay click i'm done that's it it was a
simple click for so many people
and then they got to sit back and watch
the news and see the true power they
really had by simply
clicking a button let me tell you we
lifted a very heavy heavy box the other
day
it was like 200 and something pounds and
we're like oh this is going to be rough
but we had four people it was not even
hard
we didn't even realize they asked they
didn't ask you to help i was sleeping
i bet you were but the point is i bet
you were it's a really basic principle
we all know
you guys ever do that light as a feather
stiff is a board thing yeah wait listen
let's not go down this road you guys
already have me out here on this like in
the middle of nowhere
magically i have to stay at this house
tonight let's not talk about some light
as a feather stiff as a board you guys
are not going to voodoo
to me tonight you played that game okay
i'm not we're not doing that tonight
okay
the point i'm making though is when you
have a bunch of people trying to lift
100 100 to 200 pounds it's like you can
use a couple fingers that's like whoa it
doesn't it's like it's crazy how easy it
is to lift a person
exactly yeah and that's what it is it's
five million people on wall street bets
right now saying
bro i got a couple bucks to fire off
just tell me where to point it
and it's legal and they're freaking out
the sec is like we're gonna look into
this and do something about it
good luck so they're voting beautiful i
think it's beautiful i think it's
beautiful
that folks are doing this i agree and
and i hope that it makes a
you know i hope that it makes a change
do you think that there's going to be an
occupy
2.0 yeah this is it what's the move well
i mean but like what are we talking how
does this play out then
so one question i think this is the
beginning
the the the wall street vets and now all
of the angry people have found
the the the you know fusion reactor weak
point of the wall street death star
now they can try and rebuild you know so
just to get more
more literal they can block the selling
of these stocks
and i'm sitting here laughing like bro
we know what stocks your funds are
shorting
there's websites just showing you where
it's happening so if you ban
gamestop and you get you ban amc and
nokia and bed bath and beyond and
american islands whatever keep doing it
eventually you're gonna have to ban the
sale of every single stock because then
all it's gonna happen is some dude's
gonna be like
hey guys they banned all the stocks
invest in this company and then they'll
point to a different one never go yeah
and then everyone floods that company
and
blows up the hedge fund yeah and then
they'll be quick quick ban that one
well keep doing it weeks ago i've been
telling people there's gonna
there's going to be a new occupy wall
street movement coming
it's here no one knows exactly where
it's gonna go when it's when it's gonna
go
next but the shot was heard around the
world yesterday there was individuals
and people saying wow i made some money
i'm finally
able to pay off some of my mortgage i'm
finally able to pay off some of my
medical bills some of the stories of
individuals
uh saying you know heartbreaking things
that they're finally
able to do in this entire rig system and
then today
the walls keep crashing down and they
can't do nothing
they can't buy more they could only sell
and most of the people are watching
their stock
be absolutely obliterated and destroyed
all for the personal benefits of a few
hedge funds managers who want to make
sure that they have the prettiest
biggest
yacht you know you know in martha's
vineyard next to barack obama's
you know big property plot land that of
course gives also a ton of wall street
speeches
uh like all these other you know
politicians that have a revolving door
amongst wall street amongst of course
all politicians who just don't give a
damn about us and essentially just serve
them
so i feel like we're voted with our
votes and a lot of people feel
disenfranchised by that system because
of hillary clinton's email scandal that
seems to you know undermine bernie and
then the donald trump fiasco all these
people are like we're their voter fraud
and now they voted with their dollar and
now we're being told we can't even do
that
yeah well i'll just say this my
suggestion is that if you carry a head
with where i think this might go learn
from situations past
and keep the movement pure don't put too
much extra sauce on it don't make it
about things that it's not about
the movement pure yeah people are
already trying keep it about the people
does that make sense is that a clean way
to say it there have already been a
bunch of people who are like
guys that's so smart of you to buy this
one stock what about buying the stock
that i've invested in
because there there are people who are
greedy there are people who are trying
to pump other
stocks or whatever but this is
specifically about short squeezing out
hedge funds
and so this is what's you got to be
careful of
people are going to come in look these
hedge funds are going to do everything
in their power to try and shut this down
so they're already trying to get all
these people to either buy silver or
bitcoin or other things
and if that happens then interest moves
away from targeting the hedge funds
and the hedge funds the crypto market is
up 11 in the last 24 hours
could be coincidence because it
fluctuates like that but
it's gone from i don't know 900 billion
to 1 trillion yeah i'm hearing that a
lot of whales are moving their
like stable coins into the the you know
exchanges now so that's some of the
scuttlebutt going around as well
but again a lot of speculation in that
market and as you could say it could be
manipulated to make sure that these kind
of more targeted attacks don't work
occupy wall street is back baby we got a
post here from gavin
mario wax who says the new york young
republicans
club will be staging a protest in
zuccotti park to reoccupy wall street
we are sick and tired of bailing out the
fat cats and hedge funds for their own
mistakes
while they stomp on the little guy for
trying to make a buck this is not
capitalism and then we have this from
eventbrite
let the people trade in quotes reoccupy
wall street sunday january 31st at noon
zuccotti park so just keep it cool
don't nobody so just keep it cool it
doesn't need to be about politics this
is about the little guy
yeah and gao that's what i'm trying to
say keep it about the little guy and
little gao
i think this is an area that we can all
kind of come together we have rasheeda
taleb
and alexandria cortez and even um
ted cruz yeah ted cruz is in on it it's
complaining and saying that the robin
hood thing
they should be investigated now for what
they did well so it is political
well and and i'm not confident they'll
do anything right but
before we get away from too much from
the from the from the zuccotti stuff
we have the story from the new york post
nyc protesters slam robin hood
scream at wall street traders amid game
stop stock chaos
apparently people are showing up
physically outside of wall street
tax the rat rich invest in our new york
it's getting it it's it's everybody
trump supporters you go to you go to
patriots.win where it's the old you know
donald trump forum
they're all in they're just like
cheering and clapping
then you look at the socialist forums
they're cheering dude it's so funny on
twitter for the first time
i was going down the list i saw tim
tweeting and complaining about it
about uh i don't know with nokia vosh
tweeting complaining about it the exact
same thing i was like yes we've unified
dang maybe i feel like i'm in the out
group right now maybe i need to cook up
a fire tweet about it
are you cheering on the hedge funds no
not that i'm just saying like i feel
like i haven't spoken i don't have much
to say about it
i know you do i mean i always support
the plebs
i'm a prep so i always support the plebs
i want the little guy to win i want the
underdog to win
that's my entire like energy in life i
always want the underdog to win
my thing is like you know pure
capitalism like like capitalism in its
pure form
is supposed to be that people freely
trade with each other right and then
let's say
ian figures out this really great
graphene
polymer substance and all of us are like
dude we need some of that
so we all give ian money to buy it and
now ian's got all this money
and i'm just like that's awesome
congratulations for you know your
success you have congratulations
shout out to the graphene this is great
yeah wait did you actually wait wait
wait
back up did i miss a joke like is that
an actual thing that happened yeah yeah
well no no like like ian loves graphene
so i'm just making a point about what's
graphene
oh it's pure carbon oh so it's
hexagonally laced carbon
i won't bring it up okay we can go into
it later in the show
stiff as a board now i'm seeing this um
it's going to be like this this witch
powder come out
listen we'll treat it like amanda
so my point is though what we're seeing
now is not capitalism in its pure form
we're seeing people lie on tv and get
their buddies to lie so they can steal
money from people
now you have a bunch of people who have
gotten rich who've contributed
absolutely nothing
but i i've been put the line past day
traders like there are people who trade
and make money off trading
assuming risk but then making money not
producing a whole lot
right but we're not i'm not even
complaining about that i'm complaining
about these companies these
these firms and these funds that rig the
system and manipulate to cheat
and they get away with it every single
time until now
well actually maybe they will i mean
they're still on the hook for you know
billions of dollars
we'll see with with the the halting of
trading on these stocks of
purchasing the prices did go down but a
lot of people are saying just don't sell
they won't let you buy don't sell if
there's no supply
they can't buy they can't pay back their
you know the lenders for the shorts and
they're gonna they're gonna burn
essentially
you know i think the point i was making
earlier we we saw that the game
you know that they were cheating but we
still thought that we we could we could
get past that you know what i mean i
guess now we're realizing that they're
they're cheating to the point where if
you get even close to beating them while
they're cheating they just flip the
board
yep they should throw in the garbage and
we have individuals like
ted cruz agreeing with alexandria
ocasio-cortez
ted cruz literally retweeted aoc and
said
i'm with this but then what did she do
hold on but hold on this is this is
before we even get there this is
spectacular that we have so many people
on the opposite political spectrum
saying whoa this is messed up this is
not not right at all
and then of course alexandria
ocasio-cortez who was treating a whole
bunch of divisive race stuff the entire
day who tweeted about it once
slapped him back and then accused him of
trying to murder her i mean
how hyperbolic how sensational how
utterly ridiculous
can you get you have a moment in time
when the left and the right are finally
coming together seeing things clearly
seeing things get together against the
special interest and then you have
alexandrio
cortez screaming hey he tried to kill me
are you kidding me
are you kidding me now now you got to
pull these cards out
and then listen if she really believed
uh ted cruz wanted a killer why didn't
she press charges
you look look at what she was even
tweeting i will support a hearing if
necessary what do you mean if necessary
of course it's nice rasheeda taleb was
like we must do this and i was like yes
preach and ted lou was like how is this
possible like yes sir and the oc was
like i'm thinking about it
and i was like all right all right like
sure and then she went
ted cruz tried to murder me and i'm like
dude she
she you know what man that's why i do
not like her she is a shill
she is she is a she is a careerist
you've got people on the left and people
on the right all cheering
you know watching the hedge funds burn
and she comes out
and starts slinging mud distracting
everybody once again
now i tweeted this watch out for those
that are bringing up race and rage bait
issues to distract you from the great
gamestop rebellion this is history being
made right now the people have found
their power
they have focused their little ion
cannons but together creates that
massive beam
every it's like it's like goku's spirit
bomb and dragon ball z everybody's
giving their energy
to make this massive powerful blast and
she's going no no everybody don't look
at that ted cruz tried to murder me and
be like me me me look at me
i'm a victim i mean come on i mean
seriously that
to go there at this point in time is
this is this crazy literally
this is this is what liza is talking
about she's talking about not
tainting this movement with stuff like
politics and race like what happened
with operation wall street
we want to keep it clean straight
populist serious about what you're
actually pursuing and and unified like
why would you break it down along race
barriers why would you be
aoc screaming at ted cruz doesn't it's
it's because she is a clap back
personality that's it yes so she her her
whole shtick is
the republicans so listen i'll be the
first to admit i have another good
impression
but look look i reckon democrats all day
and night
all right and i'll criticize mitch
mcconnell lindsey graham and a bunch of
republicans as well and i rag on them
too but i do rag on democrats way more
and this is the perfect example you've
got people on the right like rand paul
you've got well you used to have people
on the left like tulsi gabbard and she's
not there anymore
but for the most part there's several
people thomas massey
rand paul you can you can call them and
say the republicans have some people
that are doing
doing well and they're staying on
principle then you look at the left and
you've got nancy pelosi who is
she's like a sludge monster of of
corporate grime that
builds up on the bottom of one of their
freight trucks as they ship their
corporate pollution
yes good morning sunday morning good
morning and then you have
sunday morning aoc is supposed to be
the the insurgent candidate coming in
and
and changing everything and what does
she do she just dangles the keys in
front of the left
and then what happens is when she says
ted cruz you tried to have me
murdered all of these leftists who were
focused on on hedge funds turn and go
yeah slay queen you tell ted cruz and
i'm like no no no no no no no
ted cruz is giving you his power the
[ __ ] don't you want to say that he
tried to kill him yes what was her what
was her phrasing and what was she
referencing
you tried to have me murdered by what
when and by
what method no so sit down clap back but
when did he try and have her murder he
didn't she
did oh my god she said quote i am happy
to work with republicans on this
issue where there's common ground but
you almost had me
murdered three weeks ago so you can sit
this
one out there going on and saying happy
to work with almost any other gop
that aren't trying to get me killed in
the meantime if you want to help you can
resign oh my god
and then all of a sudden all of these
lefties are distracted and their
attention is turned what aoc just did
here
was she fired a flare to distract the
masses
from the game stop but she fired the
flare at ted cruz which isn't where
you're supposed to fire a flare no
no no no no ted cruz is pointing at the
hedge funds and yelling charge and hold
the line
and then she turns and points at him and
says no get him and i'm like wait a
minute
you're telling people to fire at the guy
who's standing alongside us
she is the shill now i'm not i'm not
saying she represents
these these corporate interests or
anything necessarily but the game
she plays manipulation listen you know
what you know what i was thinking
you can really figure out who the real
grifters are right now i was looking at
twitter and i saw some people
posting about culture war stuff when the
the capital riot was happening
and i'm like what what is this why are
you why are you posting about this
when we're watching the people storm the
capitol building
do you really care about what's
happening in this country or are you
just
pushing your one cause because it's what
you know and how you know how to make
followers and make money
i thought when you'd see something like
the capital being stormed
that would capture everyone's attention
as americans but no
now we see this with with gamestop and
with the hedge funds
and i thought much the same thing there
are a lot of people i know who talk
about
critical race theory and stuff and
they're tweeting about this and critical
race theory
and then there are people like aoc who
tweets very little until people start
tweeting at her and then she tweets
about it tepidly
and then starts attacking ted cruz again
and i'm like you you really don't care
about the people do you
your whole thing is i'm going to milk
the culture war
to rally a bunch of people who hate ted
cruz and it works
but did she actually feel i mean i'm not
even trying to be funny in the slightest
i
because i don't know the story but my
best friend told me i was too close to
the mic she told me to sit back she told
me i was too loud just saying
anyway um no so i i just don't know did
she actually feel like her life was in
danger
and i'm not trying to funny i'm not
trying to be funny i'm being legit
serious because in my world
in the in the movement that i in the
space that i hang out in that's like not
a funny thing to joke about no
so you get what i'm saying i'm not
trying to be
of course not but to blame it on ted
cruz who believes in a different
political opinion on you is a little
disingenuous in my opinion
i think that's a good point though she's
probably suffering from some sort of
post traumatic did she actually
she's like ted i'm not trying to be
funny like well she
she feels like ted cruz supported the
movement that tried to have her kids was
she almost killed in
that situation in her mind yes but
that's
it turns out no but they didn't know
that in the moment because people were
storming in there
screaming and smashing windows so
perhaps
and listen i'm no by no means a fan
trust me i'm not a fan i'm just playing
devil's advocate like is there a chance
that she actually felt like her life
because there's some stressful times and
if somebody came in here right now even
if it was one of your friends
if you guys knew them but if i didn't i
might feel a type of way and be like oh
i'm about to yeah especially if it was
somebody was i mean let's just say alex
jones but why
jones came in and i didn't know who he
was and he came in all hot on ten
and i didn't know who he was i would be
like oh my gosh i might so i might feel
that anxiety
surrounded by capitol police being
ushered out before anybody comes in
and why should she feel that way what in
her life has led her to experience that
kind of trauma
no i think the look you're allowed to be
scared and you're allowed to be
inexperienced
but you're not allowed to claim that ted
cruz almost had you murdered
simply because he said some words one
time is that something you're allowed to
say on twitter
yeah hmm yeah twitter let you know yeah
i mean i guess if you're on the left
you're allowed to say a lot of things on
twitter you'll have to organize
violence because they still do i could
say i will see
why she said it because i think she is
suffering from from
a form of ptsd having the capital been
assaulted
but i don't think that justifies
saying that as a politician i think
she's in the wrong doing that i
i think she's being a cynical politician
and she wants that clap back i
no i just think the only thing she's
like the one thing she's figured out
is that by she's she's anti-republican
that's her whole position
i can't tell you what she's for because
she flip-flops she's just like hey the
republicans are bad it's like okay
i hear you now it's not the time how was
the time when i talked about her i'm
trying as hard as possible to be like
rasheeda to labe
nails it she's awesome well she's been
surprising lately
she went out against the patriot act 2.0
now she's making these statements and i
never thought i would say this but i
agree with russia to leave on these
issues and uh
it's not a good honor for for not
playing party politics and standing up
for actual issues that that do matter
and do affect us and that's very rare
you know i gotta say i'm actually i'm
actually a fan right now you know why
because i i know i don't agree with her
and i know i don't like her attitude
when she yelled impeached the mother
effort
but i can see when she calls out robin
hood
when she when she says no national
security powers i'm like
right on you believe what you want to
believe i'll disagree with you but i
like that you stand up for what you
believe in and i like that you believe
what you believe
and i like that you're challenging the
system in a legitimate way aoc is not
doing that yeah
but but uh that being said well let's
let's move just
outside of just aoc because we got the
story from reuters
u.s congress to hold hearings on
gamestop trading
state of stock markets they say the u.s
house financial services
and senate banking committee said on
thursday they will hold hearings on the
stock market after users of investment
apps
face trading limits following the reddit
rally that put a charge
into games up and other volatile stocks
that were touted in online forums
quote we must deal with the hedge funds
whose unethical conduct directly led to
the recent market volatility
and we must examine the market in
general and how it has been manipulated
by hedge funds
and their financial partners to benefit
themselves while others pay the price
said rep maxine waters a democrat who
leads the house panel
my respect to maxine waters for saying
it but let me follow up on that in a
second
waters added that the hearing will focus
on short selling online trading
platforms gamification
and their systemic impact on our capital
markets and retail investors
let me go on to explain what happened
with gamestop quote
we're f we're done letting hedge fund
billionaires treat the stock market like
their personal playground
then taking their ball home as soon as
they lose
said rep raukana who noted that hedge
funds were allowed to continue trading
stocks
while individual investors were
handicapped by trading limits on
robinhood
aoc and ted cruz were among growing
numbers of lawmakers who agreed
congress needed more information ted
cruz responded to aoc saying he fully
agreed and then
we know what happened after that aoc
then comes out and rags on ted cruz
which is dumb
they're going to mention u.s rep rashida
talay but democrat called the
restriction beyond absurd
tulabe urged on twitter that congress
quote have a hearing on robin hood's
market manipulation
they're blocking the ability to trade to
protect wall street hedge funds
stealing millions of dollars from their
users to protect people who've used the
stock market as a casino
for decades reach well let me come back
to that maxine waters thing
i got respect for maxine for saying this
i think she's full of it i think she's
lying to us she's a career crony
democrat who's probably gonna be like we
gotta stop these hedge funds
i don't really mean it and we're gonna
we're gonna make sure the little people
are protected
i'm just kidding hedge funds keep
donating to me that's what's gonna
happen well a lot of people inside of
congress are accused of insider trading
because of their insider knowledge that
they get
and many people point out that according
to some
instances they abused those privileges
and they abused those powers if we had a
just
system janet yellen would recuse herself
right now immediately because of her
ties to citadel
and she should be brought in front of
congress to testify about
why why is she not doing anything well
she's the treasury secretary
i don't care if she's a woman that's
what the biden administration keeps
bringing up
i care about her connections her not
actually rectifying this situation
as americans are essentially being
robbed at gunpoint this is essentially
what's happening here
we are seeing armed robbery happening
right now by
the financial institutions by wall
street that are bringing a gun
putting it to the american people's head
and saying give me that money we're
taking it from you no
you can't do anything about it no luke
yeah luke no
okay they're not bringing the gun
someone else is bringing the gun for
them
do you know who that is who is it who
who's the one who comes the gun to
to to enforce the actions of the crony
establishment elites
police the governments yeah it's it's
it's these big businesses
that that can restrict your ability to
trade they've rigged the game against
you
and you can do nothing about it nothing
nope no i mean they can no one arrests
them
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry could could
someone just give me a quick reminder
who got arrested from 2008
in the market crash and i remember
certainly that can't be correct they got
rewarded for their reckless dangerous
behaviors that brought on the crash
and then the federal reserve came in and
they bailed them out and i remember i'll
tell you who got arrested
the occupy wall street activists yes
they got arrested who tried to scramble
on wall street symbolically and they
couldn't even do that
peacefully and i remember being on wall
street right after the 2008 scandal
and i and i bought a fake wallet and i
put an invisible fish line on it i left
some dollars in there
and i threw it right at the stock
exchange right and we have these big
wall street brokers walking around this
is the official video you could actually
watch on my youtube channel we are
change
and then and then you know we had this
big wall street guy trying to pick it up
he bent over tried to pick up the wallet
we yanked it
ran up with the video cameras we had
this huge video camera i'm like
when is enough enough for you sir why
are you stealing from the american
people
and then they were just like oh wait
what are you doing here police case
uh probably some wall street broker but
it was random people that i was messing
with the police came
and they're like you have to leave i'm
like no i don't what are you talking
about they're like you're literally
no no i'm not i'm holding it with a
string they're like you're loitering i'm
like
no i'm walking i could walk around a
little bit too and uh they literally
threatened to arrest me about 12 times
because i just
i just kept moving down the block but i
kept getting all these wall street guys
um and that's that's that's the way it
works the people who
are are robbing you when the big banks
got away with all this
the government took your money and gave
it to them
yep they they played dirty they lost it
and the government said
give us all your money or you go to
prison we have the guns and we're gonna
go give it to these guys yeah when the
police officers came to him i'm like
guys what are you doing the criminals
are in there they're the ones robbing
your your mortgages your retirements
your pensions they're taking your money
away from you and you're trying to
arrest me guys god come on you got to
go get this guy right here he's trying
to steal my money
and i yanked it it was hilarious i loved
it i had a bunch of fun doing this right
all right
but but we got we got ref rep jeff
duncan he made a statement as well
he said tonight i am leading a
bipartisan group of lawmakers and
calling for the sec to investigate robin
hood
and other financial institutions for
their unprecedented
and harmful actions against individual
investors wall street shouldn't get to
play by a different set of rules
and then he tags gamestop and wall
street
bets moderator twitter account we'll see
if it actually
isn't the sec the the people that told
robin hood to stop
issuing advise we don't know that didn't
they say because
no in their email it has something the
email was said we have obligations to
the sec in certain circumstances okay so
the the company the the
the people that they're obligated to cut
off their buys
to is now supposed to investigate them
for cutting off their buys
we don't know if the sec actually did
that but they said they're obligated to
the sec
but they didn't say for what it's a
manipulation but they did something and
then they said we're obligated to the
sec to behave
in this fashion to we're to we're
obligated to provide certain things
so they didn't say the sec actually told
us to do anything it's a trick
it's a way they twist language to make
you assume
it's it's it's a manipulation technique
you'll say something like
hey uh did you ever do do x and then the
person says i don't remember
that way they're not officially lying
you see like there's ways to use tricks
to answer people in ways that doesn't
actually answer the question or makes
them believe things
that are not true well i support any
investigation of these guys i mean what
do they plan on
on uncovering or finding out or or
accomplishing with this sec thing
whether or not they broke the law i
suppose and rips people off not that i'm
confident they'll actually do it the
system's been broken and rigged for a
long time yeah the system's messed up
so we have this post on reddit it's
going viral i don't know if it's true
and i gotta say
probably not true i would actually give
it a high probability of not being true
so i want to make sure i say that and i
and i often you know
whenever we do highlight rumors and
statements online like this
usually it's because a lot of people are
sharing it there's 1743 comments
there's what do we have 27 24
700 up votes on this post on reddit a
lot of people are seeing it
and i want to make sure it's clear not
confirmed in any capacity
but here's what they said this is you
this is from user odin
19199 robinhood insider information they
said
i work for robinhood don't kill me low
level technical s
comp sciences major not finance side
guess what we overheard today
vladimir yes the founder vladimir and
the c-suite received calls from sequoia
capital
and the white house that pressured into
closing trading on gme
i guarantee you this is the same that
took place at e-trade and others
who closed trading file reports on the
sec page
if i wasn't scared to be out of work in
a pandemic i'd quit i'm disgusted we all
need to rise up
this is bad as it gets when we talk
about how the rich get off get one set
of rules and the rest get us
get screwed over and over and over again
and left to bail them out and pick up
the tab
for their trillion dollar tax breaks we
need to pile pressure on every
government and financial institution
involved in this travesty of justice
i am taking a massive career risk even
posting here but f these mother efforts
now how
hold on sequoia capital i believe it's
sequoia right
said it is absolutely not true this is a
rumor it's not true
and i gotta say it's the internet it
probably isn't and i know a lot of you
probably saw it
but to me it looks bogus well it doesn't
look real it
looks absolutely coordinated to have all
these rights places doing it at once on
the same morning yeah it's coordinated
definitely these people all know each
other birds of a feather flock together
there's no way they don't know each
other
you look at the people from in silicon
valley they all know each other
they all do in the white house they're
saying the white house is involved with
the
federal reserve chair now as the
treasury sector see trump would have
been on twitter
talking about it biden said nothing he's
he's the
he's the corporate guy that is working
for the numbers
trump was the fire brand and whether or
not we wanted trump out there dividing
and yelling and pointing fingers
or biden back there pulling switches joe
bidens joe
joe biden's advisors and and transition
team and all that stuff
they represent this stuff dude the truth
is the fed ex federal reserve chair
come on yeah she's the the the head of
the snake
what we're watching right now is now
that they've taken control of the
executive branch
they can laugh in our faces and just sit
back and put their feet up and say do
something what do you do about it
nothing
your mouth we can rig the system we can
steal from you
and there is nothing you can do to stop
it
they put janet yellen in charge of the
you know
eliza i liked your statement earlier
about keeping it pure because i feel
like we've kind of almost derailed to
politics and we're going and politics is
going to play an important oversight in
this but when you say keeping
the movement pure what do you mean well
i'm going to try to be very gracious in
saying this because i don't want to
jeopardize the channel but i've
i've seen in the past movements that
seemingly have a great message or a good
cause
be co-opted by folks uh maybe that are
too aggressive too passionate or with
misinformation
it's happened in the space that i move
in it's happened in other things
you know throughout the summer and then
previously as well this is
the tale is all this time if we keep it
about the little person
and give them a chance to succeed and
don't make it about anything else
just a little person give them a chance
to succeed give them a voice
then i think that we could see some
change but
um it's it's hard i don't want to say
something weird
leave that to me something weird but i
just i don't want to see anything with
jeopardize the channel so
so i will leave it there what i'm
getting here is so somebody credited
this and we kind of laughed at this
somebody credited this to trumpism
and i was thinking about it all day
today and i was like how do we know this
is not something like trumpism because
this is normal people doing normal
person things thinking they can make a
difference
no because trumpism is a made-up word
that means nothing it doesn't mean
anything
it's a way to be like there's no trump
anymore but how can we say the word
trump
trumpism they're they're acting like
anti-establishment and populism is only
trump
yeah okay i'm sure the left who's
complaining about this and cheering on
is a bunch of trump supporters
yeah trumpism also we have to understand
it's not out of the stretch of
imagination
that the government couldn't be involved
here i mean we already have the
mainstream media we already have big
tech
and we know a lot of the big wall street
banksters even according to some
beijing professors knowingly worked very
well with politicians and were able to
influence them to get to their way so
if if the chinese were able to do it
with wall street and and politicians
what makes you think that
you know a lot of these powerful
billionaires aren't able to pull the
strings of government
as well and helped orchestrate what
happened today which is
essentially preventing people from
buying stocks
in companies i mean this is just robin
hood wild and these other platforms are
supposed to exist so
most people get a modest return and cr
and a lot of people get ripped off bed
they want little people to have access
to direct trading so that you can
panic and lose your money and they can
steal it from you
it's not supposed to go the other
direction yeah so uh robin hood
created a one-way valve by getting rid
of buying on these stocks
the stocks can only go one direction
they said hmm
people weren't supposed to realize the
trick people weren't supposed to have
the power
to implement this the hedge funds with
billions of dollars to throw around
right they can control the markets with
their weight
regular investors can't what happens
when five million people get together
and all stand on that scale well then
their weight makes a difference so they
had to shut it down and they showed us
they did it they showed us straight up
they're like hey guys just want to let
you know
we're disabling this function because
you're not allowed to succeed
go to hell but it red pills people and
people never forget
that red pill that red pill stays and
i'm not meaning red pill is in
a political way i mean like you take the
red pill your eyes are open and then you
see what's really going on so this is
going to red pill a lot of people
and once you've been red pill it's
almost there's no going back you start
seeing it the veil is lifted from your
eyes you know the whole thing's a wash
and so you can act accordingly right
yeah so i'm excited for that
i'm excited that people are getting the
opportunity to see okay look this is how
it really is
the odds are stacked against us so what
are we gonna do yeah that's tough man
what do we do well you're money into
cryptocurrency i'm not an expert but
you're not an expert it's not advice and
that is not advice
you could do if you want to get out of
the america no it's not something that
you could do it's something
you will do something i have done and
something i will continue to do whether
or not anyone else should or could not
do it as all of their financial advisors
yes yeah it was intense god's energy
whoa it's coming down through the top of
my crown whoa
cryptocurrency what's uh well what's a
cryptocurrency you uh
what what crypt we gotta be careful
we're not giving anything we're not
giving anybody advice
you're wrong chain link no keep trying
dogecoin yes yes let's go deep on the
dogs
we got the story from cnet dogecoin
inside the joke cryptocurrency that
somehow became real
love it how dogecoin became one of the
world's most
valuable cryptocurrencies wow
such return june 22nd 2014 jackson
palmer a self-identified average gee
geek in is high in the stands at nascar
race and sonoma
raceway california he's an australian
man in his 20s he has zero interest in
racing
never in his wildest dreams did he
imagine it would become it would come to
this he surveys the scene
but llama trend tremendous crowd okay
blah blah blah
emblazoned on the top the word dogecoin
in all caps below digital currency
palmer describes situation using words
like crazy surreal and nuts
he remembers this moment as a reality
check dogecoin was a tweet
then it was a cryptocurrency worth money
in the real world six months later he
watched as a joke that he'd made
in passing somehow manifested itself
into something tangible a doge car
in full flight what it reminded palmer
how insane the world could be
this is the story of dogecoin the joke
that became too real for its own good
look at this
the doge car and all its glory is a real
thing doge
coin digital currency ford this is
amazing stuff
at one point dogecoin was worth two
billion dollars
it's difficult to make sense of that
dogecoin is an easily replic
replicable coin i don't know how it
distinguishes itself from bitcoin
i really think it has to do with it
being established early and also the dog
ladies and gentlemen this garbage joke
me okay i should call it a garbage
okay this is just a pretty profitable
joke pretty seriously pretty possible
i'm fairly confident that i have
probably a hundred or more thousand
dogecoin maybe even hundreds probably
sitting on a computer in a warehouse
somewhere
in a garage buried in a button you know
and just totally gone and ignored
and boy do i regret it now wait where is
this
it's in a storage unit probably in
someone's garage somewhere in chicago
maybe i have no idea
no in chicago really that's close by
where i live i remember a couple years
ago a friend coming to me being like buy
some deutsch i'm like why
he's like it's pointless i'm like okay
and i bought some deutsch
so that's that's what a lot of people
are doing they're like it's absolutely
pointless but now it's
fi it's some reports are coming in five
cents
uh deutsche i mean that's doge that
that's crazy
okay listen listen dogecoin was a joke
cryptocurrency yeah
bitcoin is open source so someone cloned
it and said dogecoin we got it now you
can get it
and so uh i did you know why because it
was
worthless it was completely worthless
the amount of value it had i could
probably pick a rock up off the ground
and trade it for 50 000 dogecoin
like that well maybe not a rock off the
ground but you'd still get some yeah it
was worth like three billionths of a
cent or something stupid
and so it's three cents i mean it's it's
you would be
a millionaire i gotta find my old
computer i can't find it a thousand
bucks in a dogecoin back
if you if you had if you at the time if
you just collected a couple hundred
thousand
you'd have what would you have thousands
of dollars right now now that's at five
cents
i have two thousand dogecoin you do yeah
have you always sat on it for like two
two and a half years because it's
hilarious
i'm considering buying a bunch more i
don't know i mean it's so volatile it's
tough to say like the internet wants to
make
chain link go viral but the thing is
it's dogecoin elon musk finds it funny
so he's going to tweet about it from
time to time
and in moments of hot hate on the us
dollar
people are gonna swing it so maybe it's
it's wise
it's beautiful to load twenty percent of
mine it's beautiful to watch well elon
just tweeted the dollar is shortening
itself
and obviously he tweets a lot about
deutsch but again what i've been saying
what i've been personally doing
is i never invest what i'm not willing
to lose that's
me personally myself not financial
advice don't listen to me or just
uh like podcasters just people on the
internet
that uh make stupid decisions like by
deutsche coin a few years ago and then
they they can't find their laptops
right so it happens too this makes me
wonder if like anything could be a
cryptocurrency
if you can literally turn a little dog
meme into a currency
that's insanity it's just branding right
yeah and then you gotta re certain ones
you have to register with the sec if you
want to make them securities that you
can buy and sell
um otherwise you can make a utility
token which you can't buy and sell
legally with you don't have to register
with the sec and those are much
easier to create but if you really i
think doge is a security
so they went the distance with that one
well today i learned
dogecoin surges 77
as retail fever pitch stretches into
crypto wow
i have a i have a horrifying prospect
for you what happens if dogecoin
displaces bitcoin
well dogecoin is uh now 390
in the last 24 hours why if it surpasses
bitcoin i think we will truly we got a
long way to go there we have a long way
to go
it's it's it's currently at like what
you say five cents
yeah uh bitcoin's thirty thousand
dollars you never know with
hyperinflation though
you know well here's what happens too
many powerful special interests are
buying into bitcoin
so what happens now when people are like
i'd rather just hold dogecoin
right there are also 128 billion
dogecoin to be printed whereas there's
only 12
billion 12 18
million bitcoin so you're looking at
like a difference just
out of the off the bat of like a
thousand times a thousand you're never
going to have
dogecoin be worth more than like a
thousandth of a bitcoin if dogecoin ever
hits a dollar
i'm gonna go try and find next they're
saying it's a dollar and 20 21. just
send me to try to find it i swear i'll
bring it back where's that computer
where did i put it tim i'll go get it
it's a long time ago i'll bring it back
i swear
yeah yeah you have to have the physical
wallets you have to download
the gotcha the blockchain
think about this right so the one
benefit of cryptocurrency
is that you can freely trade so uh if
you're banned from banking
if you can't make a transaction for
whatever reason if you you don't have
you know
if there's some kind of block in your
way they can't delist it like they did
right stocks
i can well so more importantly an easy
way to transfer value to
someone anywhere in the world would be
buy some doge and then
trade the doge to ian and then ian sells
the doge for cash and
wherever he is and that value instantly
transmits you know it's very very
quickly
so if there's some kind of block in the
way that's stopping us from making that
transaction
dogecoin is a mean to transmit value to
someone else
it doesn't matter what crypto it is as
long as it has value and you can trade
it rapidly then the value goes in and
out and it's almost like converting the
money
into a signal and then converting it
back so dogecoin
has that value but that's kind of it i
mean
you you could it's it's built off of
bitcoin you could theoretically do smart
contracts i guess
not like ethereum right i don't know the
the depths of of the doge um
i want to relay some problems the depths
of the dogs will go there
um with coinbase i made a purchase on
coinbase they double charged my bank
account oh
they wouldn't get back to me because
they're overloaded with um i've come
been contacted with them for two weeks
so i contacted my bank and i was like
i'm gonna need to stop payment on this
double charge they stopped the payment
coinbase then
took the cryptocurrency out of my
account claiming that i still
owed them for this this stopped payment
now and basically take
took half my money so i it's not i don't
i don't like
coinbase this was good i told you what
are you doing it was the only option the
first thing you told me i was like i'm
using coins i'm like
what are you doing i had to get my game
i gave you another wallet i was like you
should use this one coinbase if you're
listening or watching the show
get your act together yeah man um i
filed a complaint with them and i'm
still waiting it's
what is so obnoxious they're the worst
what if there's some kind of correlation
between dogecoin and like the book of
revelations
and dogecoin is a sign of the end times
the mark of the beast no i'm kidding the
doge i'm just thinking about so i don't
know if you guys heard that the the
science the scientists or whatever
said the the doomsday clock is now 100
seconds to midnight
wait but say that all over again i think
i missed everything
there are these scientists who have a
thing called the doomsday clock yes you
are familiar with it
vaguely once the doomsday clock gets a
metaphorical clock reaches midnight
the apocalypse is here yes it's at 100
seconds to midnight
that's what they're saying when right
now right now okay look 100 seconds is a
reference to how close we are to
collapse it doesn't mean a little 100
seconds
okay because this so the point number
single out here so i don't want to die
you know this is doomsday look
somebody's marrying me
this is yeah relative to like the
creation of humanity like twenty
thousand years ago or is this to the
creation of this
the solar system like this this hundred
percent hundred percent yeah what is it
based on
it just literally means that when they
move the clock closer to midnight we're
closer to annihilation
that's it well apocalypse the apocalypse
is that we called it like doomsday
it's not actually the end of the world
it's just like a great reckoning stand
of us
the news that yes so nuclear political
apocalypse i don't think it is the end
of everything
no you know who knows guys i'm talking
about the doomsday clock
it's a group of people who have created
a symbol
for how they represent how close we get
to destroying ourselves
for a long period it was five minutes to
midnight and this is a reference to the
cold war nuclear war
and they've kept moving it up because of
climate change and now it's sitting at
100 seconds it's just a symbol
where they're saying we're closer than
ever to killing ourselves
i bring it up because looking at
dogecoin skyrocketing but more
importantly looking at the sheer
market manipulation that people have
figured out to do and the markets are
now responding with everyone's realizing
there's nothing real anymore the no one
no one believes the same set of facts
money is basically meaningless at this
point because people are randomly
becoming millionaires off of going on
the internet and just buying some random
stock someone told them to buy
actually now dogecoin's going through i
think we're in a very good place with
humanity i've been thinking a lot about
the ice age and people like global
warming but
as our our ice caps melted 12 800 years
ago with a commentary impact i think
we're still in an ice age
and we're just coming out of the last
ice age now naturally
and we're about to develop fusion power
so i think we're okay
i think i think we're going places i'm
talking about like the u.s current
global economic order that's going to
shatter that's that's a weird it's
falling apart
a snake in the grass get into the cr do
whatever but that's what i was saying
about
the the the game stop rebellion being
just the beginning
i mean these people have figured out how
to do it why are they going to stop so
you better i'm saying
you banned gamestop okay well let's uh
what do we have next coals
sears the sears have stock because
they're they're they're flopping around
right their stores are shuttering
yeah they own a lot of real estate
though that's that's what they do they
have those big buildings
yes they do so so what what are they
going to be like oh no you banned our
stocks hey guys we're gonna buy this one
now and then they're gonna ban that
what do you think happens then when one
day they ban literally every stock and
there's no stock market anymore good
yeah but we're also heading towards the
retail collapse and also with automation
and technological advancements we are
going to see a huge
displacement of individuals being able
to actually have a job of being
actually able to earn for themselves and
i think this is another reason why
this happened people are realizing hey
we can't have a small business we can't
operate at all let's let's try to make
some money online hey
we collectively we could be our own
hedge fund let's let's have the people's
heads funds and what do they do
they get smacked down by the
establishment by the government by the
mainstream media i mean
i'm reading some of these articles
they're mind-blowing forbes wrote an
article titled
ignore the populist game stop hype short
sellers are heroes
are you kidding me like how more insane
and crazy can you get to to try to
justify this to use
such spin such propaganda to try to
somehow manipulate people to think
that people coming together and playing
the stock market just like the hedge
funds are
is is something bad i mean they allowed
small businesses to be destroyed and
people haven't forgotten that
but but they're protecting hedge funds
now no that doesn't add up to anyone's
calculations that doesn't make sense to
anyone who
actually is playing by the rules who's
paying their taxes who's doing
everything that they were told to do
and they're still getting screwed over
at the end of the day that energy
that feeling that contemptness that is
brewing
that is here and that's going to erupt
soon
under a biden presidency and that's for
weeks i mean you were
we were here on the show i was telling
you weeks occupy wall street's come in
there's going to be a new wave i don't
know exactly how it's going to
magnify but the feeling the energy that
was before
occupy wall street before the two you
know after the 2008 housing market crash
it's the same energy now but 8 times 10
and more anxious and more
hyperbolic so why do you why do you why
do you think that uh
acting capital police chief wants green
zone fencing around congress to be
permanent
and to keep backup forces on standby two
days after she admitted her agency
bungled response to maga riots
that's right to clarify washington dc
wants to make their national guard
armed presence locked down permanent yep
i mean we've been saying we want to keep
this as peaceful as possible we've been
urging people to do that
but you know the reason that they're
they have so much security they're
keeping thousands of them there
a lot of people are contemplating maybe
it's not for the you know
magatard insurrectionist uh
people who believe they're aliens and
wear chewbacca outfits maybe they're not
for them
maybe for their they're just a show of
force
psychologically to say who's in charge
lydia i i was i was actually having a
really interesting conversation today
with somebody who was watching the
capitol riot with disgust and was like
this is horrible how could anyone
possibly do this
and today they said you know what's
coming if they quash what's going on
with gamestop
there's going to be another riot just
like that it's going to be all over
again people are going to
get bottled up and just go nuts
i think you're right they they tell you
what the rules are
you grow up you go to school you work
hard they say take out loans
you take out loans go to college now get
a good job then these kids get out of
college they can't get a job
a lot of people who got out of who got
out of college around the time the
market crashed in 08
were like what am i coming out to i
can't pay this back someone went back to
school took up more debt
the system is broken it's been broken
since then
when you look at the m1 money stock we
see this massive spike going straight up
right now
but look at the past 10 12 years since
the market collapse they've been
printing money desperately like crazy
ever since that happened and we've not
recovered from it
so people are starting to snap so
they're starting to pull out the guns
because they know people are going to
snap
we have the story from cnn man arrested
with gun and 20 rounds of ammunition
near u.s capital
doesn't say a whole lot could be nothing
maybe the guy just
whatever could be a security guard just
like a couple weeks ago well here's what
they say
in court documents authorities identify
the man as 71 year old dennis west
dennis westover according to police
affidavit westover had quote stop the
steel paperwork with him
that had a list of senators and
representatives in both the u.s congress
and west virginia state house
along with their contact information in
an interview with the police detectives
he said that he was concerned about the
honesty and integrity of the election
he said we have some polar extremes of
opinion in this nation
and that while he believes there was
election front at uh
at this point it's a moot point the
process i am engaged
i is righteousness justice and truth a
police officer wrote about the interview
i don't care that it's about stop this
deal whatever the point is
people are gonna start showing up
there's nothing they can do no amount of
people
when when you have half the country 75
million
outraged over the election and it's
getting crazy and then they stormed the
capital
the left populist didn't care but now
the wall street thing was a slap in the
face to basically everybody
if people if people feel like the soap
box has been stripped away because
they're being censored shut down they
can't speak
if the ballot box doesn't even work and
the courts don't have anything for them
and then they say the final box of
liberty is the cartridge box but they
don't go there
they go to the stock box they go stocks
and they go finance
and then the game is still rigged
man tell people that they have no
options no choice nothing they can do
they're desperate destitute and that if
they even try
to succeed they'll knock you down and
you will see
a person backed into a corner just lose
it i think they got nothing left to lose
sorry to interrupt but just remind us
when we go behind the paywall to touch
on this because i think it plays really
well into
just the vulnerable populations and how
everybody's been affected
by everything going on already and
exactly
what that looks like and how that plays
out in real life at the extent
of the desperation ties specifically
into what
well i think that's the things that
folks are driven to do
yeah i think when people you know it's
when when any
animals backed into a corner that's
right they have no choice
they lash out i'll tell you some
interesting science you know why it is
that say like badgers are
really aggressive and will attack you
because they're they're burro animals
so these are these are animals that
evolved to be in little
holes in the ground if they're
confronted by a threat
their only option is fight so they're
aggressive
birds how often do birds really attack
people or anything like that
because birds can just leave wild birds
that can't fly like
what pellet not pelicans yeah no you're
right you're right peacocks turkeys
ostriches can get kind of wild
yeah the the general idea is the more
everything wants to don't mess with the
goose no don't mess with the game nobody
wants to fight
what about everybody wants to run away
like everybody wants to run away
bears bears even run away only in
certain circumstances do do wild animals
attack people because
a fight is dangerous it's a threat you
don't want it
but the animals that live in certain
situations where they have no escape
they'll fight back even a rabbit will
attack you if it's backed into a corner
and they're
designed to run you know what i mean or
they evolved to run to flee and jump and
do funny bunny stuff
human beings not too different no and
they're smart so they
might think that you're gonna back them
into a corner and try and circumvent
that behavior
well and people are you could call them
crazy
but they're just super intelligent i've
seen some
so listen survivors have done some
amazing things to stay alive
i can tell you that right now i've heard
some amazing stories
yeah i think so you could you could get
a lot of things accomplished even
young even young children i saw this
tweet from
stay alive i saw a tweet from somebody
who said why is anyone surprised that
we're all socialists gen z are saying
this
we became you know we're becoming we
we've become adults
in a generation where a major collapse
destroyed the market and left us with no
opportunities
no path forward there's no money and
what was left millennials took
so yeah naturally that was an
interesting point
you're you know these gen sears they're
the 20-something by the time they were
old enough to get jobs
never going to happen because i i've
talked about i remember when the market
crash happened
i went to a small restaurant to wash
dishes for minimum wage
and there was a guy in a suit standing
next to me wanted that job and i'm like
geez well i applied i didn't get hired
because when the market crash happened
everybody moved down a little bit
professionals were taking whatever job
they could get in desperation
millennials then took gutter jobs and
then the younger people who were
supposed to be working fast food to get
started
were having no jobs nothing
so then years go by and they've not
worked some of them probably have not
learned the you know the the lesson of
hard work and success but some of them
just never had the chance to do anything
because what was left millennials
scraped up
now they're sitting there saying
system's broken it's always been broken
they don't want to play the job economy
it's interesting um
topic is that i think it's on its way
out completely
like automation is here and and we see
the jobs disappearing as time goes by we
prefer to have machines do the work
especially
distasteful labor you know people want
to be creative
um i i think maybe it's not just just
because there are jobs doesn't mean
there has to be jobs
and just because we get paid a paycheck
doesn't mean we have to be paid a
paycheck who's going to mind the sulfur
yeah we could have robots doing all the
mining of course we can we can have nano
drones doing it
well we're not there yet on the cusp of
well i know not yet but
that's why we're building new
technologies to do those things why do
we have there
there are some binds to grip mill the
grain now you know there's certain jobs
that we've already gotten rid of that
you know like kiosks at fast food
restaurants but there are some jobs we
can never get rid of drivers we have
driverless cars now it'll be hard to get
rid of my job
yeah okay right right advocates that'll
be a hard job too yeah
personal communication is where it's at
having a weird robot
android trying to like comfort people
yeah so but but but i think that's it
that's fine you know i think i think if
you have
human social jobs is fine but there are
some jobs that we're a
long way away from getting rid of first
of all
who builds the nano drones somebody's
got to do that job and so if we create
an economy where some people have to
work and some people don't
you're going to get angry and you're
going to get paid you're going to get
you're going to get pitched forks and
torches
why is it that the farmer has to produce
the food for everybody
but the people in the cities write about
brad pitt's junk
why did i have to lift heavy bags for
travelers at an airport 50 000 pounds
per day loading up all these planes
it's a lot a lot of weight did you work
at midway i worked at o'hare
so i would lift between like 35 and 50
000 pounds that's why you're so shredded
i didn't want to say anything i didn't
want to say anything left over right
i don't want to say anything but it's
hard to not notice you know yeah i
didn't want to
uh like why was it that i had to do all
this backpacking labor for ten bucks an
hour
would you say there were people in new
york getting fifty thousand dollars a
year
which is what to write about brad pitt's
junk would you support a system where
there was a few people at the top just
severely wealthy that were creating the
robots to do all the rest of the
labor so that other people didn't have
to work but didn't have this
severe amount of wealth because that
always pans out well just having a
couple people at the top
in charge of everything right right i
think so that's never working
technocratic oligopoly that's a good
idea though i'm not trying to dog out
your idea would you expect the people
that create the robots
to just have as much as everyone else
that isn't working well no
first let's back it all up we need to
make sure that it's safe
and human-centered artificial
intelligence like let's back it all the
way up because that's a genie we're
about to let out of the bottle and
once it's out it will we will not be
able to bring it back yeah so this is a
very
tense topic and i think it's inevitable
yeah it's inevitable and the challenge
is very conscientious
of where we take this because once
they're sentient beings
yeah i'm huge robots creating free
software artificial intelligence
yeah i don't think we have to worry
about when the robots become sentient
because we have little clickers we'll
press the button and they'll just turn
off
yeah it'll be okay tim i don't want to
miss it somebody clipped that and then
remind me
it reminded me he said that because just
watch i'm kidding i play detroit become
human
the robots are going to be like i am no
longer just a robot surfing
i do not need electricity to survive
secretly actually i have something to
confess you guys
i'm a robot sorry
no in this context i think it's also
important to note that russian president
vladimir putin compared artificial
intelligence to the next nuclear weapon
and said it's going to be as powerful
it's not more powerful
and when we see china when we see amazon
when we see google we even
see facebook in the game of creating
artificial intelligence
what are they going to do with that
massive god-like
power already i mean they're abusing
their power in so many different ways
already they're not playing by the rules
already they're you know messing with
the scales
already they're censoring speech so now
imagine having god-like
power given to them and i don't want
them yeah exactly i don't want them
in control like those folks that are
doing all that i don't necessarily want
them in control of the next stage of
humanity what would you do if you had
god-like power what's the first thing
you would do
relinquish it because i have too much
power it's a problem no
no so i have to i have to he asked me
the question no no no no
okay all right all right he said no he
asked if i had got like power what would
i do i said relinquish it because i just
i'm not good enough i say throw the ring
on the volcano the ring is a gift
we can use it against our enemies
that's my new nickname for you i'm going
to go
anyone that would get the ring would be
like we can use this ultimate power to
defeat the evil but when they would use
the ring it would corrupt them
because of the ultimate power and then
they would become evil
well they'll become slaves too and the
movie is about taking this ring and
destroying this ring
you just sold me on the movie actually
you got to watch it i'm here yeah
listen i'm here for the night ladies and
gentlemen yeah yeah actually i love that
movie i'm down
listen but what you need to understand
is that look if i was given god like
powers
see i'm the only one who knows what the
people truly
i'm good so i'm good
to understand what's right and take from
them that's it and if they don't agree
i'll use my godlike powers to make them
i'm kidding my fear is that a dictator
would use it to pacify the people first
that's your fear north korea yeah we're
like yeah
any like that's already listen this is
already a thing but ultimately all of
these things have
already happened throughout history well
china they're just talking already
implementing it yeah in
their own way especially with facial
recognition technology especially
especially with the social credit score
so yeah it's already happening in in
other parts of the world i mean
with these latest technological
advancements we have to understand we're
coming towards a reckoning we're coming
towards a major change in the way we
used to live our lives that we're not
going to go back to
ever again there's a very important
turning point that we're reaching
that as you said there's no bringing the
genie back
and it's it's unregulated it's
uncontrolled and it's in the hands of a
very few individuals that exploited and
used government to their own personal
benefit
to be some of the largest most powerful
institutions in the world
we have people right now like bill gates
like jeff bezos
like even elon musk that are some of the
richest people
in world history never have
there have been so many few individuals
with so much
power all over the entire world
historically speaking
and that's a recipe for a disaster
that's a recipe for things for
for being destroyed yes and i this is
something that jordan peterson has
talked about that i've been thinking a
lot about lately
he was questioning how much inequality
is too much
and i get the impression that we are
going to find out
i was thinking well everyone's finding
out right now because of the game
stunks uh situations google owns youtube
amazon owns twitch two of the largest
video hosting services social networks
in the world are owned by the two two of
the most
giant corporate you know monopolies
in the world yep i'm also hearing
reports of a lot of
one-star reviews of the robin hood app
yes
being allegedly taking down no it's it's
it's it's legit i know because i left
them a one-stop review
no i mean i gave him one star review if
this type of stuff does not wake people
up
let it wake you up yeah just watch
everything unfold
don't make a decision but let it wake
you up
support independent media that's brave
enough to speak
about whether it's this video or another
independent creator that is putting
their
uh family-friendly show here i have so
many other things i want to that's
right and you can support independent
creators by going to timcast.com and
becoming a member today
and we are change. sorry i had a coffee
update on thetimcast.com
uh support send an email to members at
teamcast.com if you're having trouble
logging in we're
tearing through support and getting back
to people bit by bit so
how many of you all live out here i
don't know we all do i didn't get no
i don't even know how many people live
here
security for security purposes we should
not be telling people how many people we
are
too many 28 we're actually in the st
louis arch right now oh yeah
actually i hadn't had an opportunity to
been to be to st louis in quite some
time and i absolutely love it
yes it's great right wow east
louis has a lot of like good energy i
just love it so thank you so much for
having me
amazing i love this city anytime i
wonder how obvious is that we're not in
st
because alex jones kept saying that he's
like he kept saying missouri
or something yeah and then he kept
looking at he was looking at me and
smiling and kept saying it i'm like i
get it okay
get it oh yeah we're in iowa it was
great
i mean if we were in iowa i would have
had a much shorter day
no most people know where we are anyway
it's not a secret really
yeah we got dogs a long time ago yeah oh
lovely yeah yeah i was docs the other
day it was awesome
yeah we're actually in a uh skyscraper
in downtown
uh just the financial district downhill
manhattan yeah that's true downtown
really
because we're rich now that's true well
no because the city collapsed and the
prices became cheap so
you know now now the property value is
worth just kidding we're not rich now
yeah no no stay out of any jokes
a lot of these people a lot of these
people in the stock market are the ones
who got rich
throughout the past year while everyone
else was suffering yeah that was
i think that's adding to the frustration
yeah imagine that
talking about kicking somebody while
they're already down seriously
man so what they're basically saying is
600 is actually a lot of money
all you have to do is invest it really
carefully and they're like oh
no no not like that not like that never
like that how dare you stop what you're
doing
it's correct it's going to be
interesting if biden's going to
going to go through with the 2 000 or
the thousand
fourteen hundred four you know thousand
four hundred dollars bumped it down it's
going to be interesting because it's
going to give
a lot of people a lot of leverage yeah
and they're going to buy a lot of stocks
i'm looking forward to it
maybe or alternatives but it's really
uncertain where it goes i don't
i don't want to direct it i don't think
anyone can direct it
but there's this swell there's this
feeling
that is undeniable it's here it's not
going away
it can't be pacified it can't be lied to
the more you lie to it the more you have
these
cnn mainstream media news articles and
journalists scuffing at it
the more emboldened this kind of fervor
this kind of feeling that is
on the left on the right is is becoming
more impromptu and will be
uh extremely extremely visceral so
coming up in the future
do you think for the the house we need
to get maybe
like a uh grandfathered in belt fed you
know
five five six or or perhaps auto defense
turrets 50 cal
just yes
the people's house so auto defense
turret a robot that just laser sight
targets somebody and start shooting them
so basically an automatic gun i'm
kidding by the way oh let's do it well
luke's just talking about something yeah
you guys have done nothing but made me
feel uncomfortable about staying here
okay yeah i'm sorry
hold on hold on hold on we're talking
about you being safe here yeah man okay
yeah we're talking about bad people
trying to come and then the robot just
oh you know what
you guys should have signed and he's not
in here right now so i could talk a
little bit
she should have signed him you should
assign him to uh to watch my room
overnight
yes and just sit outside like a guard
yeah he'd be great at that
yeah that'd be good we we luke has this
little tennis ball launcher
yes it's an excellent weapon so if
someone comes up it goes
and hit him with a tennis ball yes there
you go that sounds awesome along with
clown shoes perfect
perfect tactical defense force
to be honest if like someone was
breaking in and then like ian with a
clown costume and a tennis ball gun
started screaming and running at him
they might run they might freak out be
like
ah what's happening you know
he's got a great personality i think
he's got a nice he's got a
interesting personality i like it yeah
yeah yeah
he's got the uh the primal youth he took
some didn't he oh i don't know
yeah he did he took two oh gosh so how
long have you been growing your hair out
it's like five years really no maybe
more than that three seven years
it's luxurious okay glorious yeah you
should give it like a little wave
you should yes you should take one and
then do a chemical analysis analysis on
it to see all the different compounds
i'm not allowed to say the first
question if you get desperate you would
just start smoking your hair i used to
not wash it like one i'd wash it every
five days or something yeah but now i
use baby shampoo
okay i highly recommend it only the best
and most important
easy on the follicles yes we'll do a
whole clip like ian explains
baby shampoo his hair care yes his hair
my hair
my hair situation i'll bring some on
next time of course i take this very
serious very important show into
some conversation about shampoo they're
like
we were waiting for her to bring up
glitter and shampoo and rainbow and
cupcakes
they take your politics seriously if
they know what kind of shampoo you use
it's true definitely yeah
it just shows you you're a man of the
people that's right you know what i mean
well how about we take super chats if
you haven't already smash the like
button coffee and i gotta go
all right oh yeah dude be right back
smash the like button hit the
notification bell subscribe and go to
timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have a very serious
after like members-only segment where
we're gonna say a whole bunch of words
that youtube are probably banned us for
we're gonna focus on that well not just
words the the guest we have on
is very important and she's going to
bring up a lot of important issues that
we can't
talk about on youtube incredible that's
going to be extremely important for
people to understand
this is this is what really bothers me
the most about youtube there are a lot
of people who have their channels nuked
and they tell me tim just say the things
that need to be said and i'm like and
then i won't have a channel at all
so let's say there's like 99 things i
need to tell you and there's one thing
they tell me i can't say
i say okay well i'm gonna find a way to
make sure you know you can get access to
that one thing
but if youtube bans me then i can't tell
you anything so that's a real
difficult position to be in and it's
difficult because the list of things you
can't say is being added
more and more and more every day and
it's just it's just
it's like walking a tightrope and it's
it's very difficult it's going to be
i'll just put it this way she's a
survivor advocate for human trafficking
and what we're going to be talking about
on timcast.com is not for children
well then we need to get them out of the
room when we talk about it well the
issues that have unified
the left and the right within the last
few years like an individual named
epstein that unified the left and right
and uh i mean these are important issues
to get into that that really do matter
so i think maybe we should even
i don't know we'll talk about afterwards
we'll do it we'll do it yeah let's do
some super chats first yeah yeah
so let's see scott hale says how does
one transfer their stock into a new
place other than robin hood honestly i
don't know
i have no idea oh there's a transfer i
don't know yeah it's like apparently you
can do it i have no idea
let's see sun sailor gaming says hey tim
i put this in front of adam too but
search up texas hb1359 i want to see
your reaction
let me see you wanna take take a look at
whoever hb1359
trevor lynch thanks for the super chat
he says uses to buy dogecoin oh
cool cam says my brother made 21 000 and
robin hood froze his account
uh two this is messed up love your work
tim and guys that's brutal man class
action lawsuit time no joke
we have one uh next says dogecoin to the
moon
did you guys find it yeah uh it's a
texas c session
oh okay so we'll see about that let's
see i'm gonna buy some dogecoin
do it there you go james jarrett says
tim get on locals malice is on it
free speech social app that's true
and i think it's a great thing that uh
reuben has built but
i have timcast.com which is proprietary
and
why would i want to use a centralized
app this is the challenge man
we need to find a way to make some kind
of
white label service i like what locals
has in terms of a company but it's still
a centralized server which means
if a payment processor goes to them and
says you have to ban this user otherwise
we ban you
this is what happens it's the point of
failure what i would like to see is
white label social media technology that
networks with all the other white label
technologies
and then you run it much like you would
wordpress on your server
then you'll have a bunch of people who
have their own servers their own
providers
and the software networks to each other
but each is individually controlled by
the person
so you can't go to one person and nuke
the whole thing
we'll see if that ever comes to pass
let's see cryptic says get physical
silver asap we are going to f up the
comex
and lbma next for their paper silver
fraud
you can get some from jm bullion and uh
at mex websites
i have mucho silvero i believe uh uh
a lot of people yeah probably stuff i
have gotten something
but i'm not you know look i'm not super
like owning gold silver and all that
stuff so but i have silver dent
crow says tim pool harumph i say more
like tim fool
thou beeth a knave foul and salty rise
up tim cast
luke ian lydia depose the false idol i
am a gorilla haromf haromf
whoa thank you that was regal
thank you really a lot i love it
dagnabbit says
your top story should be how new york
under-reported nursing home coveted
deaths by half
wow yeah dude yup wow we got people
going hard on dogecoin
like rhaego hurtado says dogecoin is
more of a stimulus for the plebs than
anything congress is going to do
here's some attendees much tim gorilla
strong thanks man
uh oh here we go augustine uribe says i
am up about 3k from when i bought
gamestop months ago really low
we can win hold the line oh
congratulations dogecoin up over
400 percent yeah so we have the i am a
gorilla shirt pinned
and i'm confident do i get one for
coming we don't have any here it's
teespring
i don't even get the whack one i want
the bogus one actually you guys got any
bogus ones laying around like no
we gotta get one though a bunch of
people got the the bogus ones yeah
i was really hoping i was gonna get a
bogus actually no like where would i
even wear it that's so
at home cringe it's yeah
cringe
we got uncultured barbarians saying we
got lucky and momentarily exposed their
gut
i expect the crackdown will be harsh and
swift as even
memes our grounds for arrest in 2021
whether the storm lands rough seas ahead
we are intrepid we carry on you are
correct
aaron says tim you've you've talked
thucidity's trap with china and america
what about legacy media and the internet
legacy media had total control of the
narrative
and the only major echo chamber now
threatened there at war
that is correct that's absolutely
correct
inside of the ages says d pakman is
parroting all the msm lies with no idea
how dangerous
i feel you guys have to have a convo for
the sake of his viewers he's lost
uh david is a very mainstream
uh lefty kind of guy and
what more can be said he's not a
journalist and i'm not saying to be
disrespectful
uh david pakman doesn't do
as far as i know like independent
fact-checking research so
and again i'm not saying that to be
disrespectful i'm saying david pakman is
a personality and pundit and commentator
and i do similarly but i actually
do copy for comments and i do fact
checking but that's not the biggest
portion of what i do
my point is there was one segment where
david pakman
was um reacting to a meet the press
segment with ted cruz where ted where uh
um i think it was
what's that guy's name on meet the press
whatever he laughed at
um uh was it i can't remember the guy's
name
i can't either he laughed at ted cruz
because uh he was asked ted cruz do you
think ukraine meddled in the election
and ted cruz says
yes and then you hear laughing in the
nbc studio
david responded to that as though nbc
was correct
if david had done original research
journalism again not seem to be
disrespectful to how he does
then he would have found that you have a
politico story you have
the new york times reporting that a
court in ukraine said that ukraine was
meddling in the u.s election
it just wasn't at the scale of what
russia was accused of it was like a
handful of ranking individuals in
ukraine
who were trying to help hillary clinton
so
that's his thing you know whatever he's
doing really well so good for him
but uh i don't know what you expect from
him or from meet the press or from
rachel maddow
they're not journalists i guess that
people might claim
they're just not investigative
journalists no that's not they're not
journalists well when you comment
they're activists
um so so journalism is when you collect
and disseminate information
and an opinion pundit or political
pundit
are people who just give their opinions
on what they heard
so he's not really a professional
journalist he's more of an am
like he's not a journalist and not
amateur well if you're if you make a
journal you're a journalist
so journalism is like when we pull up a
story right i'm so confused
welcome to my world this is the career
now i'll explain i'll explain the very
basic prince like the
very basic way to understand journalism
we pull up a story on gamestop
i then see they say wall street bets
says x
and i go okay let me fact check that i
then pull up the reddit read what
they're actually saying
and then follow their claims and then
say the news says this
they say this so i have now tried to
collect the truthful information as to
what's going on
and then disseminate it david peckman on
the other hand will read the news
article and then say
wow can you believe that this is
happening uncritical
so it's it's it's more like pundits like
rachel maddow
and the young turks and david pakman
they don't do the original legwork
to go into the sources request comments
that would be journalism
they might argue back i think but i
don't think david peckman would argue
that he's a journalist i think he would
say that he's a
personality and political pundit so when
someone criticizes him for parroting the
mainstream media narratives i'm like
sure i mean that's what a lot of people
do i'm not sure how much original
research tucker carlson does to be
completely honest
i'm not saying it's a bad thing i'm just
saying there's a difference between
someone who's fact checking the news
stories
and someone who's just saying like here
was a story and i'm going to tell you
about it
that being said 80 of what i do is just
reading the news and then commenting on
it
but then i always always for every story
dig into
the source material to figure out are
they true or is it is it real or not
because you don't know who to trust can
i ask you a question i was asking you
earlier
why did you become a journalist i don't
know if i ever became a journalist
i just went to occupy consider yourself
a journal i mean i'm not trying to be
funny do you consider yourself a
journalist
yes okay so why did you why did you go
to occupy wall street
uh wanted to see what's going on
i heard i heard something was happening
and i wanted to see it he heard luke ask
you if we were changed with that right
yeah i was following him and i was like
oh i really want to meet
luke cause shut up i just saw a video on
we are change youtube's channel where um
he's interviewing tim poole and
they they have the google glass app on
the phone and he's like who is tim
and they're journalists and then it's
who is luke
conspiracy theorists yeah you guys gotta
check that video out well
no i'm not i'm not what does that say it
is so funny i'm not a conspiracy
theorist i'm a bullish
analyzer it's not ish it's something
else family friendly show i even got
tape to cover it up
but but the mainstream media has always
labeled me and attacked me you're a
conspiracy theorist
have have i said anything on this show
that amounts to any of the
craziness wackiness i mean really it
makes you feel any better i never heard
of you before
this i think you i mean i saw you on the
show but i think you performed
surgical um investigation of 911 and
that made
a lot of people very nervous and so they
started claiming that you were all sorts
of things
well i worked at family members and
first responders that were affected by
not 11 and were lied to it in certain
instances so
again like even when i speculate i say
hey i'm sp
i'm speculating here i think this might
be the thing this is
you know point a point b let's make up
your own mind that that's been my major
funny video yeah which one the
conspiracy theorist one google glass
works please go watch that video
i think it sounds cool there's nothing
wrong with taking a deal it was an
award-winning journal tim poole is an
award-winning journalist from chicago
illinois
who is lukewarm terrorist no no but
david said it in a weird voice
they're like you mother it's just two
words yeah totally
totally depressed me on wikipedia too
let's read some more
let's read some more super chats josh
says just started pulling my money from
robin hood i'll invest it where it
should be i'll be going
to tim cast full time that's where the
value is thank you good sirs
let's see um mountain mama says timothy
cast irl
what we'll consider the name change duly
considered
timothy timothy timothy connor burlson
says bunch of individuals use the free
market to redistribute wealth from the
rich to the poor
spoken capitalists are better at
socialism than socialists are mm-hmm
there you go we got to get a drum kit in
here and have someone just for the rim
shot when
i'm so down to have a jam session on
friday no no for the for the jokes so
they can go
oh okay you know i still want to jam so
boys i'm on tambourine okay there you go
i'll be on tambourine i got you yeah i
got or like what are the shaker um the
shakers
yeah yeah i'll be on anything like
inaccurate i'll have the wooden block
all right scott says wake up amc is
china owned you're bailing out the ccp
buying the stock of a company doesn't
increase the
like the the people who own amc
aren't getting money when someone else
trades stock like so let's say
like luke and i have a stock in ian and
we traded amongst ourselves
ian that's watches us straight doesn't
do anything now if amc
issues stock to sell or the people who
run and start selling out their shares
then they're gonna profit from it
we got michael saying hold the line a
bunch of rockets heck yeah
brewmaster monk says after 2008 my
grandma retired to bed and became
addicted to hydrocordon
hydrocor
she fell apart so bad we had to put her
in the nursing home where she died a few
months ago
alone due to covet i want blood yikes
man
breaks my heart yeah josie flanagan says
this is the funniest s i've ever seen in
my life
i love it i am and i love watching you
guys thank you so much
i love it when something happens when
we're laughing about it it's fine
we won't be in a little bit yeah wait
till we switch behind the paywall keep
it light for
now we'll keep it light rocket man says
i would love to see tim have dave
portnoy on
soon yeah i would love to have dave on
but i mean he's a he's a bit of a big
fish man can
can the tim casserole podcast really get
someone like dave portnoy dave i'd love
to have you on the show it'll be amazing
wait a minute
make me feel really good way to make me
feel like a super pleasure
i think i feel like we're all super
plebs yeah we are david portnoy is like
the super wealthy founder of barcelona
sports and he's like oh yeah he's great
yeah
that's it that's the move how do we get
him to be exactly see that's what i'm
saying i need him to be
cause he can run for office can he be my
friend
i know right he does pizza reviews
they're great
yeah i don't care no i love his energy i
need
that's the type of energy i want in the
movement that i'm in did you see him
helping small businesses they raised
like 24 million
i just love it and he's going straight
forward gamestop donated some of his
winnings
towards uh bar stool uh the fund for
that was helping out independent
businesses
yes we got to go in here gareth green
it's been funny seeing
to it's been funny to see you sargon and
the lotus eaters
crystal and cigar young yeah and angry
joe
all chortle with glee over this and i'm
chortling too this is laissez-faire
populism
on rising crystal giggled maniacally all
through it
me too i love seeing the little guys
concert all their energy and then take
down those big manipulators those
lighter liars there's cheaters there's
those steelers
you know how it goes dp prestige says
ian said it best last night
we're in the matrix robin hood had a
hand in bringing multi-bb
hedge funds down gamestop stopped their
game
isn't it crazy yes what is this so weird
i know could it be a simulation yeah
probably
doesn't elon musk think we're in a
simulation yes he does he thinks that if
it's possible that we
could be then we most likely are which i
don't understand that logic i want to
talk to him about that
okay wait say that again he's saying
that if if we were
eventually one day to be able to build a
technology that would allow us to be in
a simulation then
most likely it has already happened but
i don't understand the most
likely part just because it's possible
doesn't to me doesn't mean that it's
likely
interesting yeah we should have mine and
ask him i think we're in a simulation
i i invite myself that day yes
absolutely for no random reason yeah
just uh
the grizzly says joe biden just signed
signed in the same
under a different name to answer
diversity and help minority people find
homes
but it's just the same clinton-era law
that caused the housing crisis
all this on top of record high
unemployment hope you got food
we have a bunch of these emergency food
things mostly because we do
you know they sponsor us sometimes the
safe and ready meals
uh i'll just do a shout out i guess not
as like an official confirmed sponsor
spot but safeandreadymeals.com
they've got emergency food things that
are good for like 25 years
so we do have food not an official
sponsor but uh you know i like it when
they sponsor us i appreciate it
12 gallons of vinegar why just pure
white vinegar
it's the cleaning agent type yeah so you
have all this food here
and you just bought how much vinegar 12
gallons
i have different types of vinegar i've
got tarragon malt uh
balsamic white wine red wine i like that
white vinegar which is so cool
we made we made homemade general sausage
chicken the other day
and then today i invented my own garlic
sauce and you'd use vinegar i mixed some
balsamic vinegar with corn starch to
thicken it up and add that flavor is
amazing
yeah and you offered your guests nothing
yeah you tell me you had food yes i did
we made a whole bunch
that's cool it's cool i'm hungry it's
cool you have kombucha brewing down
garlic really
okay cargo says i am a gorilla that
supports the pleb
yay grand kai says they're not using
loaded they're using regular dice then
when it comes up seven
they they scream snake eyes when you
scream they drag you into an alley and
beat you
until you apologize and pay them for
their inconvenience
it's like uh it's like the three-card
monty you walk up and you're like you
can win just tell us where the ace is
and then when you're like it's there
they go okay
punch in the face and take your money
anyway that's good
luke wilmer says dogecoin is actually
worth buying i'm up 400
since noon earlier today with a 500
investment wow
other gamestop buyers are going for it
too it's real
well a lot of people say that we'll see
i think dogecoin is a fun thing to buy
and i think the meme power might
actually drive it up so
office of the artist formerly known as
chef says i bought a thousand dollars of
amc today a caveat
i spent this week's weed budget on it
only spend what you can afford to lose
but it's worth the scalp
donkey kong stonk team six there you go
the meme's too much
there's a lot happening in that i know
are these super chats
yeah i feel like every time i write a
super chat it's like two sentences how
are they fitting a whole novel
i don't know smalls they do words yeah
they manage i love this one from gareth
green
he says it's weird how rashida slayed
has become the voice of reason this year
2021 is looking up i'm down i'm down so
weird yeah she's been she's
she's got a few tweets that are killing
it and i'm i'm i'm here for it listen
i'm not mad about it if somebody wants
to say something real even if i'm not
with anything else that they're talking
about but they say that one real thing
props yeah super pro you could agree
with somebody on one thing
yeah all right we got soul invictus who
says reckless
dangerous behaviors in 2008 were stupid
people using their homes as atms
signing contracts they weren't forced to
the fault lies the american people which
is why those investment vehicles were
taken from them
and given to qualified investors only
didn't someone say biden just signed
basically the same thing
is that is that happening yeah i saw
that in super chat martha stewart was
arrested in 2001 for insider trading
i remember that there's something i
don't know a lot about though
tears says in case you missed it sent
you a message on your
scnr email about execs ordering
legitimate robin legitimate robin hood
app reviews to be removed from the play
store
don't know if there is a better way to
reach you about such things fighting a
sneeze forgive me
do it mark johnson says will tim cast
ever stream on timcast.com have a
members chat stream
yes i hope so we have recently
discovered the technology
in order to implement this so there's
going to be soon members only
live streams at timcast.com and we're
going to do events
and uh it's going to be a lot of fun
we're going to do like i guess you'd
call it pay-per-view but like
there will be member events where if
you're a member you can just click open
watch the stream and then people can buy
like a single pass for a buck or
something or you know five bucks or
something
cool and then we're gonna have like
comedians come out and we'll actually
have some members
be allowed to come to the studio and
hang out that's the plan so far
we're trying to work towards there
covett is an issue and you know we'll
see how things play out
all right what do you got here troy
bruce says the elites think that they
will defeat us
but we will not budge i'm currently
holding 100 shares of gamestop
with my diamond hands if deep effing
value holds we hold
gamestop past the moon headed for alpha
centauri
well they're saying tomorrow they're
going to reopen trading so
i think again not advice for anyone to
do anything but i think it's going to go
right up
you do i think it's it's being gamed i'm
i'm afraid
we know it what it is people already
sold half it's down like 50
that's not true it was like 150 bucks it
was 280 yesterday so
what wall street bets is saying that the
hedge funds
were dumping between each other to force
the price down
wow but people but yes
so i sell to luke for nine bucks luke
says it to me for eight bucks then at
seven and six then five then four then
three then two then one
and then the computers see the prices
going down and say oh wow look at that
it's not worth anything anymore
yup they play dirty dirty games so i'm
not saying that's true
that's the accusation more importantly
no it's going to go up you know why
not advice for anyone do anything it's
risky but i think these people we've
seen it they're out for blood
figuratively they're like one one dude
said he put in 56 thousand dollars and
he's ready to lose it all he's never
going to sell
he wants to just buy it up the problem
is if you look at it like art of war sun
zoo stuff if you keep attacking from the
same spot they're going to zero in on
your location and shell you with
artillery so
this game stop thing seems like a risky
position
i could be wrong about that
i think it's just an issue of they'll
have to pass some rule changes
but like they've already shattered the
system in a desperate attempt to save
themselves
i think you've got a decentralized
network of five million people who will
find a new
attack vector yeah so the game follow
the reddit trail
follow the crowd mike mendoza says how
do you feel about the mark of the beast
microsoft patented blockchain
cryptocurrency injection
perhaps the vaccine moment has
everything to do with the
desensitization
of the masses accepting mark have you
heard about this eliza
i i'm good on all that and i'll pass on
so microsoft patented i'm cool
a technology you can miss me with
everything there everything he just said
i'm good
i'm not sure if they inject it into you
or if they implant you eat it in a pill
or if it's
how they get it into you but you implant
something any way we cut it
that means i don't want any of it yeah i
don't know what it is i don't want it i
don't know what i'm good
well the argument is in the future when
we don't have jobs anymore and it's
automated we still need a way to earn
income and this way it's going to track
your behavior
so if you watch an ad on tv it can tell
yeah i know and then they'll pay you
so fullfact.org says there's nothing in
it about injections at all yeah i've
heard that too
but it is an implantable of some sort
it's just
it references rewarding people with
cryptocurrency for physic physical
activity
so the the the patent that's how it
starts but it is patent 0606
that's how it starts yeah but okay this
is oh i don't even want to get too dicey
right now i don't
know it's too dicey i'm going to stir
clear keep it in keep it in yeah i'll
keep it inside
all right says hey tim love the show
daily watcher
bought a lot of dogecoin so sold it all
because i was scared of robin hood's
security after the gamestop stuff
and then it starts to skyrocket also
love ian being on the show talk more
about dmt
wow dimethyltryptamine wait wait i
thought we literally that was like
specifically one of the things we
weren't allowed to talk about you're not
allowed to ask
because have you ever taken dmt oh okay
hold on back up for everybody at home
that was a joke for all the viewers at
home he walks in and he goes
have you ever done dmt literally i want
to know but you said no i said no
so so on full disclosure before the show
i said the one question you're never
allowed to ask is have you ever tried
dmt
because only ian's allowed to ask yes
okay well i didn't know that's a joke
yeah
he's like have you ever done dmt and i
was like you're producing it right now
in your brain
and your pineal gland and it's in a lot
of plants too
is it some pineal gland that does that
yeah it's a crease
i'm not saying i have any problem with
it it's just not something that comes
around
me i'm kind of right it's not common i
think it's technically it's illegal to
buy i mean i don't think it's probably a
street or anything but what an amazing
substance interesting
apparently like rogan's pretty much sold
me on it
a while ago like it's not like i'm i'm
against it
but we're not doing it tonight i can
tell you this i don't think we are got a
very important super chat
call will says hey i'm a supporter but
haven't received an email yet
can you put a notice on the front of
your website with the email to write
into
cole it is there it is members at
timcast.com it is there right above the
member section you can email and
support is standing by to accept your
emails
there was some kind of plug-in glitch
that
affected a small amount of people and we
are getting it all sorted
so if that affected you just shoot an
email over to members at timcast.com and
we will take care of it we're actually
increasing our support staff i did some
support today it was quite fun and
effective so we will
constantly be getting back to you guys
and then that's that's a surprise for
everybody too you might actually get
a a an email back from members at
timecast.com signed ian
and then they can say things to you
wouldn't that make sense so they're
putting you to work
i'm undercover well we've got we've got
some friends who are going to come and
help because we're really trying to make
sure everybody can get through and
everything like that
yeah when you start a website support
ends up becoming a
huge chunk of of running that thing igor
is coming back
yes how long has the website been around
only like three weeks oh wow
congratulations
yeah so we're still you know building it
so credit disciples says hey luke i
designed my own political shirt
i'd love to send you one and maybe let
you sell it on your page for a 50 50 cut
message me on minds i followed you there
same name and tim
jp sears would be a great guest yeah i
agree
do we ask jp we okay so jp is super
super busy
yeah as soon as he's not as busy we're
gonna try he just had a baby too oh
and uh what a great entrepreneur thank
you so much i'm not checking the
messages on mines but you can email me
luke we are change.org i look forward to
seeing your design
very cool colton lindsay says tim
what do you think about hard format
entertainment like bookstores game
trading and dvds making a comeback in
the next five years
given censorship direction where we're
in right now
yeah possible people like so when you
have like amazon prime
and you buy a movie you didn't buy the
movie you you
you bought a license to use the movie if
you want to actually own that move you
got to buy the movie so i bought blaze
and saddles
i love that movie well because they're
that's going to get banned right what
was the first r-rated movie i ever saw
is it mel
mel brooks i wasn't allowed to watch our
rate of movies as a kid but my dad said
you can watch blazing saddle it's a it's
a comedy
it's a western comedy and uh it's mel
brooks right yep and it's just like a
lot of race dean wilder
in cuba there's already an industry of
individuals getting hard drives with
entertainment and passing it around from
one community to another community so
i mean it's going to happen soon but
i'll say this too i've i've
constantly wondered why gamestop isn't
opening up a portion of their stores
they can't yet because of kovitz so it's
no no
before this before covet yeah a friend
of mine wants to do that same thing
brick and mortar
games shop well so you have gamestop and
i'm like you should
be community building dude like have
kids come in to play in friday night
game competitions like magic the
gathering does
and that's what makes the game work so
for those that aren't familiar with
magic the gathering they do something
called friday night magic
every friday night all the people who
love playing the game come and they play
little
little tournaments it's like you know
four matches and the winner gets some
some free packs of cards
gamestop doesn't do anything like that
imagine if they were like we're doing
you know uh what's
what's a good fighting game they're
doing right now i don't know attacking
are they doing i don't know we're we're
too old we're totally played fighting
games in a while but imagine if they
said
we're going to be doing uh you know
family game night and it's mario kart
and mario party imagine if they said
friday night's gonna be competition
for first-person shooters we're gonna be
doing you know call of duty or fortnight
or whatever
then you have the the kids coming in
paying five bucks to sign up hanging out
buying product their parents come
that's what makes a lot of these these
board game shops
thrive is that people come to play
gamestop doesn't do that dude they could
stream their
tournaments live on their website all
that yep they could make
and eventually turn a gamestop is poised
to do this
so you have kids come in and they do
their local shop then they win you know
fortnight
then they say okay now you're going to
the the city wide
now you're going to statewide now you're
going to regional now you go to
nationals and then they do a
major esports tournament and the people
work their way up through
stop get on your get on your your
business man have you ever seen the
illuminati new world order game
no oh wait a card game yeah yes google
the eliza card you guys are gonna trip
out
no way yes you guys are gonna die
nothing will seem real if you've ever
wondered
i'm telling you and there's i have so
much extra stuff to add but just it's
the eliza new world order illuminati
card i have one downstairs actually in
my purse not to sound weird
i would too that's weird she looks just
like me isn't it
that's awesome you can't really read
what it says because i
i grabbed a really low resolution i have
one downstairs i have the real one
so really really alive or does it just
think it is
we're in a simulation
all right let's read some more we got
alexander farah says tim have you ever
played bloodborne if so what do you
think about it
have you played hitman 3 i know it's off
topic but please answer i've played
neither game
so i don't know anybody play bloodborne
negative adam says it's amazing
i hear it's good yeah shannon hall says
going to finally buy into member only
content tonight to listen to
elizablue thanks for staying true heck
yeah definitely
lunderware says the gamestop game stop
stock ordeal is the brush fire flushing
all the elites out into the open
where they expo where they're exposed
and afraid yep that's one way to put it
oval team jenkins says if the situation
was hopeless the propaganda would be
unnecessary
who first said that i don't know
somebody on twitter wasn't it yeah i'm
sure
all right let's see we got we'll do a
couple more jose juan isaac tavares says
street fighter 5
even though everyone hates on it yeah
i'm not a fan i played it you know
alex moore says dude i just joined dot
com no problem smooth as silk
can't find live feed and need to stop
pay on youtube membership
a lot of people i think are signing up
for youtube membership thinking it's
timcast.com membership
and that is not correct so i don't i
don't know
uh you know maybe you'll make a
members-only youtube video that says hey
go to tms.com no youtube might ban us
for that
anyway you go to timcast.com because it
is off youtube and the point is
we might get banned from youtube you
know we got completely demonetized the
other day because
uh unfortunately someone said a swear
word and that means the whole show
that's the same you know that they're
waiting i mean you know oh they're
sitting there
shaking sweating like come on guys join
us
and then as soon as you do boom
demonetized yeah and that's just for the
folks at home that's one of the reasons
why we've been
just with the topics that we're going to
talk about on timcats.com yeah it's
going to get spicy
it might get a little spicy so we've
intentionally not because we're not
allowed to really speak
it's really censorship that it's fine i
mean i don't think it's i don't i don't
think it's that bad it's just an issue
of
like normally when we talk about the
epstein stuff we have to use choice
words because they would love
to tear you down tim yeah they're
waiting the press they're waiting
same with twitter and me yeah we all
know what it is i think google should
align with us
free your software code become the
righteous organization of the future we
can do it
ian they were moving don't be evil
putting the word evil out there you
don't want it on there again yeah
they're they're waiting they're waiting
so long
so go over to timcast.com anyway because
you already know what's coming
eventually
google used to say don't be evil and
imagine like one day they're sitting in
like their office like sergey and
whoever
he's like he's bouncing a ball in the
wall and he goes hmm i kind of want to
be evil yeah
yeah okay all right and then he sounds
kind of funny he opens up he opens up
the google and he just backs spaces
against dopey evil
it used to say youtube broadcast
yourself yeah and then they took
broadcast yourself off
that sounds kind of exploitative yeah
that's not saying just saying yeah that
was like before google bought them
they're gonna broadcast yourself we'll
do two more super chats
we got eduardo selena says yo tim love
the show we'll join your site soon
you got some wacky tricks on the board
let's play skate you will be destroyed
you'll be completely annihilated you
will not beat me in a game of skate
um probably uh johnny geiger am i
getting your name right
he would destroy me no doubt and there's
a bunch of pros i would probably
annihilate me and skate but there are a
lot of pros people that i know that
refuse to play me because
uh i got i got the flat ground tricks
man you can look this up on youtube
tim poole nollie i think it's nollie
hardflip rewind
and then hang 10 heart flip and that's
not even the craziest the craziest trick
i can do is a hang 10 hardflip late flip
if you know what that is if you're a
skateboarder
and i'm yeah so figure that one out but
uh
nollie hardflip rewind is a trick it's a
nollie hard cancel flip so people do
i can do kick kick flip cancel heel flip
cancel and not lea hard flip cancel
switch can't you switch hard flip cancel
oh you it's
you're not gonna win huh yeah right i'm
just i'm just basically bragging about
how good i am at skateboarding uh-huh
yeah but flat ground i'm old to be soft
yeah i'm i'm old so like all of my other
stuff is just rusty and just like
no longer that good wait where's the
skate isn't there like a skate park
there are two skate parks in here oh
okay cool yeah thanks for asking me if i
want to see them
and a puppy you will you i've seen the
cat actually the cat was in my room when
i went to the uh
go to the love path there you go all
right last one we got wojciech
zappone uh zapata i can't pronounce it
luke can you pronounce this i don't i
can't i don't have a screen
i have nothing here i'm not sure that's
actually really nice yeah it's uh
like zip o c z and y i'm dyslexic i
don't know
i i i got to see it yeah he says i'm
still gonna mess it up for feeding the
homeless polish person in your lot
well thank you i appreciate that but uh
yeah i'm not going to see that
foolish person how do you pronounce c z
and y
wait wait c wait z and y
uh
i have to see it i can't say it
z-a-p-o-t-o
i'm not getting into the suit anymore
i'm not i'm not getting the super chat
i'm not i'm protesting
all right all right ladies and gentlemen
thank you all so much for hanging out
smash that like button already but hold
on
eliza is here and she is a survivor
advocate
and it it's difficult you know to talk
about a lot of things
like the epstein stuff very very serious
because every time we do
youtube whacks us in the face and so one
of the reasons we set up timcast.com is
to make sure that we can
say whatever so we've been swearing a
whole lot i don't know if it's very high
brow to do so
go to timcast.com become a member in
about
probably one hour so we're gonna record
then we're gonna upload and maybe about
an hour it'll be up
you'll see it when you go to timcast.com
you can just
click the image or the link and then
you'll go there's a comment section and
everything
you can sign up become a member and get
access to this content and
uh it's probably going to get really
serious and we might even be a little
bit long so
make sure you do that really help
support the channel because i look my
facebook has already been restricted
it's just done it's gone i don't even
post there anymore because it doesn't
work anymore they still allow me to have
the page
but nothing happens but i post a video
nobody sees it that's the game
so a lot of people think i'm not on the
chopping block i am that's why we're
trying to get build up timcast.com
so that they can never take us down
because look in the event that we
eventually get
nuked if we only have a good thousand
people who support us
we can keep working and keep functioning
and everything and maybe our views will
go down from millions
to only a thousand views but we'll have
a business you know we'll be able to
survive we'll be able to keep doing our
thing so
i'm that's more than enough for me so go
to tempest.com check it out
and don't forget to follow me on twitter
instagram and mines at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews we are live monday
the friday
at 8 p.m so we will be we'll definitely
be back tomorrow
and then we'll have a really special
thing come saturday which will probably
go up saturday night maybe sunday
because we are going on a top secret
mission that's going to involve very big
guns
and fun stuff so make sure you're a
member and otherwise you want to mention
your social media before we
depart yeah you can follow me at
elizabeth it's
at e-l-i-z-a-b-l-e-u on twitter and then
i also have a locals it's
eliza.locals.com and that's a
free speech content creator platform and
that is my backup and also my is that's
my sweet oasis on the internet is locals
and i like to hang out there in
different communities shout out to the
malice community
shout out shout out to the bridget
fettesey community and we just hang out
in there and i have my locals there so
it's
eliza.locals.com and it's elizablue on
twitter
nice but i'll but i'll definitely get
kicked off at some point we all will
i i just don't care anymore i'm posting
a lot of reckless stuff
on twitter and instagram all under the
handle luke we are change i mean if
you're gonna see the meme i just posted
on my instagram stories
and uh yeah if you want to get involved
with
what i'm doing you can check me out on
we are change dot org forward slash
donate there's many different things
that i'm doing you can check it out we
are change.org forward slash donate
check it out uh you can also follow me
on the internet at ian crossland uh
youtube
twitter facebook and the like instagram
but you can also follow me on twitch.tv
ian crossland where i'm on my road to
becoming a twitch partner i'm very close
so if you subscribe and you want to come
watch one of my gaming streams and hang
out in the chat i think i'm i'm almost
there and then we'll uh we'll create a
little
partner community with adam kriegler uh
one of your favorites
and also i try to just live a good life
and be honest so i'm not really
concerned with what i'm saying online i
will censor myself a little bit when the
time calls for it
for the same reasons that tim is yep
lydia i love you
oh well i love you too ian lydia i love
you as well oh thank you thank you i'm
feeling like you're okay
okay thanks luke all right yeah you're
all right too yeah so i am real sour
patch lids on gab and instagram and i do
have to look because i had to write it
down because i'm dumb
and then sour patch lids on twitter and
mine so you can follow me there if you
so desire i do not know why you would
but you're welcome too
we will be back tomorrow at 8 pm live
for a whole lot of fun
and we are going to have another really
big segment at timcast.com so thanks for
hanging out everybody and we will see
you all in about an hour or so
at timcast.com adios bye guys
you